an FBI agent has come forward blown the
whistle on overt political bias in the
agency saying that most of these cases
against right-wing extremists they claim
are entrapment now I think this is the
same FBI agent that's been suspended
after calling out overt violations of
the fourth amendment in the Constitution
and surprisingly the sixth amendment but
uh I think for most of us it was obvious
it was happening but I do want to
commend this agent for coming forward
and doing the right thing apparently
there are many more I think there was
maybe around a couple dozen or so FBI
agents who've so far come out and blown
the whistle and this is particularly
important why well the doj is being led
by a man who got lost on stage he got
lost on a stage you guys see this the
Biden video was out yesterday but we'll
talk about it today where Biden is on
stage and the thing that's crazy is
after he walks on the podium he has he
has Cornholio hands you know like
Mr Burns hands where his hands are like
this and he's like looking around
confused like and they try and Gaslight
the media like no that's normal it's
like dude it's not normal when he tried
to shake hands with nobody and then he
looks around confused used the dude is
just not there and then we got videos
from his son and you're like oh it's
like just All in the Family everything
they're doing so we'll talk about that
the reason that's important is because
Vladimir Putin is mobilizing 300 000
troops preparing to mobilize up to a
million threatening nuclear weapons and
uh our commander-in-chief is as
explained but more importantly the Air
Force is now doing diversity inclusivity
and Equity training or whatever telling
them no longer to use gendered words
like Mom and Dad and I'm just like okay
you know we're not going to win this one
because if that's our military and and
Putin does nuke Ukraine I don't see the
US effectively retaliating in any way
we'll talk about this and a bunch of
other stories silliness and uh big news
the economy is about to implode surprise
surprise but most of you can feel most
of you can feel it already before we get
started head over to timcast.com become
a member and you'll get access to the
exclusive uncensored members only show
Monday through Thursday at 11 PM we're
gonna have one of those episodes up for
you tonight at 11 PM I'm think it was
what it was Tuesday we played Mary bang
yes yeah because we can't say the other
word but you know the game and then it
was particularly funny because uh Luke
is a funny guy and we had a good time
and if you want to see that stuff don't
don't have your kids in the room when
you play it because we swear a lot and
we talk about naughty things so smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about the
news and much more is Mr comfortably
smug thanks for having me pleasure to be
here who are you well I would say that
uh I'm probably best known as being kind
of like an Internet troll who
antagonizes uh the left online and and
now I've even got my own show look at
that you got your own show ruthless and
uh we have another individual here
Michael Duncan yeah pleasure to be here
this is a beautiful place yeah no I
appreciate it who are you well uh I am a
republican consultant uh met this guy
comfortably smug on Twitter and we
started this podcast we have
two other co-hosts John Ashbrook and
Josh Holmes we've got a consulting firm
we deal with a lot of Republican
politicians and he trolls people on
Twitter all day and so naturally those
two things fit together like a hand and
a glove and so we started a podcast yeah
I think it's you know it works well for
a podcast you're like hey those those
zingers you're throwing on Twitter we
can talk we can say those words into a
microphone and people will listen huh
amazing right yeah it works out you do
look very comfortable thank you and smug
great to be here it's funny because you
do especially a thumbnail it's like
you're looking good you're like that's
right
you should see how he comes in the
studio right before we do our production
meeting you know like he's the last last
one in the door sauntering in hey guys
what are we talking about today well we
were just working for eight hours
I am the talent
of course Luke is here hey guys that's
an interesting shirt you guys well yeah
I wanted a shout out you know Mr
Epstein's friend uh Bill Gates he just
had another product launch today
supporting new lab made GMO corn which
will allegedly help Africa in its hunger
crisis and help the climate in Africa
yeah that's why I watched that video
that's that's such a creepy video I
tweeted it and it's so cringy and it's
nasty it says Ah you can't you can't
it's just Bill Gates holding a corn very
weirdly acting like he's just gonna put
it somewhere where the sun doesn't shine
but that's another topic he's he's here
having a great time on a private island
with one of his best friends if you like
this scene you could also wear it on a
t-shirt on thebestpoliticalshorts.com
and because you do I'm here thanks for
having me who are the island boys the
island boys are you don't know who the
real island boys are no uh well Bill
Gates and Jeffrey Epstein but there's
another rap group called The Island boys
who uh SoundCloud rappers who are also
uh semi-professional boxers and uh
online trolls as well a lot of face
tattoos yeah oh there you go now I get
the shirt there you go yep there's your
cultural reference for the evening I'm
excited for tonight I love Comfort I
love sorry I can't talk love comfortably
smug on Twitter excited to hear what
Michael has to say let's get into it all
right ladies and gentlemen here's the
first story from the Washington Times
FBI whistleblower counter terrorism
cases against alleged right-wing
extremists mostly entrapment shock uh we
all knew that it doesn't matter that
he's saying it because people on the
left don't want to hear it won't believe
it and they'll tell you the news report
is fake news anyway so we've learned
nothing and there's no new developments
thanks for hanging out we'll see you all
next time
it's good yeah but but I mean that no
look look with all due respect to this
FBI agent the reality is that we do need
this and we need more of it and so I I
really do want to commend this agent for
coming out because we rag on the FBI a
lot because of what the depart with the
Washington field office has been doing
especially with Trump but Donald Trump I
think in his Hannity interview said he
said uh that a lot of the FBI agents
voted for him I think that's true I
think that there's a lot of FBI agents
who are good people but are too scared
to speak up so I can only say first and
foremost James oh Keith's got your back
I mean you you look at what Veritas does
for their whistleblowers they make sure
that they're not going to be left high
and dry so I would only recommend and
anybody not just the FBI but anybody
that if you're witnessing illegal or
unethical you know actions at your
company or whatever within the confines
of the law blow the whistle I mean you
know I'm not a fan of just like leakers
for the sake of leaking there's and
there's been a lot of people who have
done that in the past and like no no if
you're if you're there and dude is like
the Constitution and you're like no and
they're like we will punish you you'd be
like hey someone help like that's good
but this guy went through the official
channels and he was left high and dry
because he was fired he was kicked out
of the FBI uh officially suspended
officially suspended but but of course
he was also suspended because he said he
wouldn't go on a raid that was
specifically targeting January 6th
individuals and his allegations I mean
interrupt but it was because they wanted
a SWAT raid on a misdemeanor charge
exactly he was like one real no dude and
and what he's saying is absolutely
mind-boggling he's talking I mean not
mind-boggling to to us everyone knows
this but this is official confirmation
of them cooking the books exaggerating
the threat of domestic terrorism using
overzealous January 6th investigations
to harass conservatives and also
innocent Americans so this is a major
big bombshell he talks about how he was
specifically he himself was taken off
human trafficking and child abuse cases
to the point where he says there was
real life effects where children were
hurt because the FBI changed focuses
from investigating human traffickers and
child abusers to going after innocent
people according to him that were just
even around Washington DC on January but
we do have a correction a correction and
an apology this is not the the same FBI
agent this isn't there's actually
there's two big stories right now this
is they say the second came from Kyle
Serafin an FBI agent of six years who
was recently suspended by The Bureau he
was suspended but there was another guy
you see that story what's his name was
it Stephen friend friend yes 37 year old
SWAT team member that refused to go on
the SWAT rates that was that guy that's
who I'm talking about right now right so
so this Kyle seraphin is a different FBI
agent who has recently suspended he he's
worked in multiple field offices
encountered Terror and conducted
investigations of alleged domestic
extremism so we have two different FBI
agents who are outright like this is
unconstitutional both got suspended I'm
willing to bet there's more but good for
these men these are these are the heroes
who are who are look I think a lot of
people get into law enforcement for the
right reasons but the systems themselves
are fairly broken yeah so if you're if
you're like I'm gonna come out expose
this and that means I'm out and good
good that's what needs to happen just
just really quickly before I give it to
you guys the New York Post is reporting
that there's over 20 FBI whistleblowers
and they're talking about especially
with this friend guy he's talking about
specifically the FBI post de facto
designating a grassy area outside of the
capital as a restricted Zone when it
wasn't a restricted Zone in order of
course to prosecute innocent civilians
that were there on January 6th and this
is a huge huge mass of allegations that
I think are worth listening to and the
fact that this friend guy was fired is
absolutely a huge huge Miss Justice well
I think number one you know just think
about being a normal you know FBI agent
who wants to do their job and you see
what's happened to the bureau and the
justice department writ large over the
last five six years I mean how can you
not be outraged you know I mean we have
the president United States right now
um remember that speech with the red
lighting and everything and he's calling
half the country domestic terrorists and
these Mega Republicans are trying to
destroy America and then two weeks later
a guy runs over UV for being a
republican extremist right and and
that's I mean the timing is not random
because we have an election coming up
here you know in 40 odd days and you've
got the president United States saying
that you've got the FBI raiding the
former president's house now you've got
the AG in in New York
um you know suing the president and his
kids all of this is political theater
right to try to mobilize their base
ahead of an election and I mean not just
that go all the way back to James Comey
right you want to talk about entrapment
I mean that guy went to president-elect
Donald Trump and said you know
congratulations Mr president-elect hey
did you um urinate on some Russian
hookers
um because there's this dossier and you
know look I mean this is salacious stuff
you know but I just want to share this
with you for your own good for your own
good and then what did he do he walked
downstairs and he got into his his limo
and typed up all the notes right because
he was trying to entrap the president he
wanted to see how the president would
react to it there's no difference
between that and this
and when you look at the priorities of
of the FBI at this point where they're
spending more time going to school board
meetings trying to call parents is
domestic like anyone basically who
opposes this regime is a domestic
terrorist Joe Biden in that speech
basically said if you oppose me you're a
radical domestic terrorist so you know
exactly like like Tim was saying is you
end up with these cases where you have a
liberal who just runs over a kid for
being a republican but that's
intentional they the first step for them
in this process is to dehumanize right
that out group right well that's the
path towards genocide of that list we
saw go viral right
yes uh and and also Steve friend he's
specifically also saying that FBI
domestic terrorism cases are being
opened up on innocent American citizens
who were quote nowhere near the capitol
on January 6th based on quote anonymous
tips and Facebook spying on people's
private messages so the fact that people
are getting raided the people that the
fact that people are getting swatted for
for just expressing messages that were
political is is such a nasty thing that
the FBI would be partaking in that of
course is destroying any semblance of
any form of Justice which of course they
have long since forgotten what it even
means in my opinion well they have a
problem with the FBI where they're
looking for like white supremacist
domestic extremists but the demands
outstripping the supply so you know this
is what they're left to have to do yeah
and they're talking about pressures from
higher up saying hey we need more white
supremacy cases we need more domestic
terrorism cases it's like this is this
is the allegations from the
whistleblowers exactly it's like the cop
towards the end of the month that has to
hit the ticket quota yeah you know so
he's looking for people who are speeding
well they're doing it for an election
quota they need they need that narrative
in the Press because it's the only thing
that motivates Democrats at this point
Democrats we've seen in the polls are
mostly now becoming white suburban and
making more than uh six figures yeah so
what motivates them I guess abortion so
their good friend the good friend of the
Democrats Lindsey Graham comes out with
that bill the 15-day Nationwide abortion
ban and like every Republican
collectively goes we literally just
argued states rights on that issue and
now what are you doing and why and it's
just he's holding up a sign saying vote
Democrat basically well anything you can
expect from them if if you ask you know
any voter you look at any poll
um in any of these key Battleground
States here ahead of the midterm
election the top issues are the economy
inflation crime and the border right
it's not abortion so what what Lindsey
Graham did there is he just highlighted
the one issue that mobilizes their base
and distracts Republican candidates from
talking about the things that are
actually going to win them elections and
if you look at what the Democrats are
running on with this upcoming election
it is abortion and very interestingly
according to a lot of different sources
they spent tens of millions of dollars
propping up uh right-wingers
specifically Donald Trump right-wingers
and also local elections as well yep
yeah I mean they spent millions of
dollars in the Colorado Senate race
trying to elect uh odais upon the guy
who ended up winning the prime Mary I
mean the Schumer's uh pack spent
millions and millions of dollars to let
these folks and then they they cry every
day on television about how democracies
on the on the verge of ending in this
country but they're you know try to
elect
um you know the the right most
right-wing candidates in these
Republican primaries and how do you
square those two things of course it's
all theater at the end of the day yep
they're giving them millions of dollars
yeah and then they're saying these guys
are so horrible they're so bad here take
my money go go ahead if you want to run
against you it's it's it's absurd but
how do you and there are people that
believe it I mean come on that's
I don't I don't know what you do at that
point because if it really does come
down to an election of people who are
not even paying attention to the most
basic of news Democrats and their packs
are funding the Maga Republicans that
Democrats and Joe Biden are claiming are
the apocalypse but there are people who
are just so ignorant and don't pay
attention that they're sitting out there
being like Oh man these my Republicans
are bad why are they getting so much
attention oh we gotta we better vote
against them it's like bro they're being
you're voting for the people who are
propping them up in the first place I
think the vast majority of Voters uh
don't agree with the Democrats framing
of any of this and if you actually look
at you know who voters Trust on various
issues like restoring faith in democracy
isn't actually an issue that Democrats
lead on funny enough despite all them
talking about restoring democracy and
stopping Donald Trump from you know
subverting the election and yada yada
all this stuff you know Republicans
actually lead on issues surrounding the
election and securing the election and
all those sorts of things things so it's
it's it I think it's going to fall in
death deaf ears and I think the reason
why they're pushing that message so hard
is they don't have anything else to run
on what are they going to say we pass
the inflation reduction act that didn't
reduce inflation like I mean that's the
thing is their entire premise in this
election cycle you know there's about
six weeks left all they have left to do
is to try and distract voters because
every day every American field this
economy is getting worse crime is going
up the border is very clearly not secure
so so the you know when the Democrats
control the house the Senate the White
House and this is the result it's not
like they've got a record that they can
run on they have to completely distract
everybody yeah well this is what I keep
saying not everyone is going to get an
abortion you know what everyone does do
buy gas yeah and if that's not enough to
get them there's other huge factors like
the cost of food people can't afford to
eat they're literally taking out loans
and maxing out credit cards it's
unsustainable I I just I don't
understand how we're even competitive
how there's even a competition in the
polls at this point with the economy on
the verge of imploding should you think
that people would just be like okay
we're done with this but I guess the
issue is Republicans suck so you know
what are you gonna get well a lot a lot
of people are saying third party you
know younger people too I I think of a
part of the problem is okay well what's
what's you know this group of Democrats
got going for him is basically every
major news organization on on in the
country will push whatever line that
they need they can pretty much you know
the tech companies will kick off anyone
who you know left-wing groups want gone
like the number of people who've been
censored from social media whether it's
Shadow band you know permanently if they
can ban the for the performer president
of the United States like you know they
can ban anyone they want and and you're
seeing that happen right now and the
election cycle I think yeah I think what
you're getting at there is there is sort
of like a non-response bias from a lot
of people who've just been worn out I
think from covid and lockdowns and all
of those things that they don't
participate as much in the censorship
too smug like you mentioned but I think
also and we've talked about this a
little bit on ruthless
you know when when you're talking your
average uh voter you know in the summer
or you know before Labor Day they're
busy they're traveling they're going on
vacation they're with their kids now
their kids are back in school now that
we're post Labor Day and you're starting
to see all of these polls move towards
Republicans and the reason why is
everyone's waking up and looking around
for someone to blame because they blame
Joe Biden they already blame him you
look at the right track wrong track in
the polling in this country or you look
at his approval and man he's like 37 38
approval right but they don't
necessarily associate that with their
Democratic senator or whatever but now
little by little those voters are
looking around they're saying well how
can I express that frustration with Joe
Biden oh you know what I'm going to vote
against Catherine Cortez master I'm
going to vote against Maggie Hassan
well I'm hearing people saying that the
the stream is Shadow banned and
notifications aren't going out and stuff
like that it's been a recurring theme
yeah and so I was just checking my phone
and I got I got an auto post outside of
the video stream some kind of unique
YouTube Auto post that says Can you spot
the manipulation in some weird little
cartoon and it's a video but it's like
YouTube created a special post only for
them it looks like and then it's just
like some guy watching a video and then
when you click it it's like how to fight
misinformation so we know and
interesting we know what's going on we
know what's going on with YouTube and
then there was a story that uh Jack
busovic was uh tweeted about
actually I'll pull up the story here
from the uh The Washington Post and
we'll talk about the censorship in real
time
from The Washington Post inside the
Civil Rights Campaign to get big Tech to
fight the big lie for a month civil
rights groups have unsuccessfully
pleaded with big tech companies to
bolster their election policies
correction a group of activists are
lying about what individuals have said
and what they believe in an effort to
get their political Rivals banned and
the problem is no matter how many times
they say it YouTube looks at the content
and goes they're not breaking the rules
so right now I have to wonder about us
being Shadow banned and I think we are
um you know the weird thing is our clips
that we post on this show are doing
really really well they're doing better
than ever and the live show seems to not
they're not sending out notifications
for a lot of people try to justify this
saying oh well you know maybe you're
posting too many clips now we're doing
the exact same thing we've always done
yeah we do like four Clips per day and
then we do the show they're not sharing
the show so if you want to help us fight
back against censorship because there's
nothing they can do share the video be
the notification it's the best we can do
otherwise they win
so here's what happens I get I get hit
up by uh some journalists from The
Washington Post we talked about it a
little bit they mentioned Jack besobic
they mentioned me they mentioned a few
other people and they claim that we Rose
to prominence in 2022 pushing the big
lie incredible they email me this is
fascinating and this woman is like so uh
you're you're included on a list of 77
individuals who have who have claimed
Biden hasn't won fairly and I was like
when did I claim Biden didn't win fairly
pretty sure I'm constantly saying Biden
did win and uh been ragged on by Trump
supporters for doing so and the left
made a video compilation of me mocking
me for saying Biden one so like what's
your point she sends me a list of tweets
she's like here's the tweets where
you've called out fraud and I'm like
okay and the tweets are like Elizabeth
Holmes can make it a fraud GoFundMe
accused of fraud I was like what does
this have to do with the election
and so they include me still in this
story and so what I think is happening
is that YouTube they're politically
biased what I think is happening is we
keep getting these stories they try and
claim that we've broken the rules but no
matter what you like if YouTube took us
down claiming we did I'd sue them in two
seconds for breach of contract because I
know the rules and we did not break them
so what can they do in the background
they can Shadow ban they can do things
like this to suppress the views make
sure people can't see it and then they
can try and appease the activists and be
like oh look we're doing everything we
can to reduce misinformation but they
can't explicitly take action against us
it has to be subversive well and the
other thing is who do they choose to
elevate right and it's not it's not just
YouTube but like if you look at the
recommended videos or recommended
podcasts and the Apple podcast app or
the stuff they're highlighting for that
month I mean have you ever seen a
conservative show up there
why why so uh people have have pointed
this out all the time
we regularly will you know we we had
like in the past month 60 something
thousand concurrent viewers it's
political off season in the 2020
election we were getting 150 000
concurrent viewers on the show never
trending like that that should have been
featured as their top trending live show
or one of them and they just would never
do it so like outright they try and Silo
shows like this content like this now
that we're into the October surprise the
uh time frame it's no surprise that
we're now hearing people being like I
can't find the show it's not popping up
some people are saying it doesn't even
appear on our page itself that they have
to go go to timcast.com or type in the
URL manually youtube.com timcast IRL
live and once again if everybody who's
watching just shares it and posts the
link there is nothing they can do to
censor it Shadow Banning won't work then
yeah YouTube essentially decides if
people will ever see your content or not
and there's many different underhanded
things that they could do to make sure
people never see you even though you
have a large subscription base even
though you're consistent even though you
have a schedule it doesn't matter I I've
been through it all throughout my entire
YouTube career and they could mess with
you in the search I remember I couldn't
even find my YouTube channel and I typed
in we are changed I typed in exact
titles of videos that I did couldn't
even find it they do it through of
course limiting notifications
demonetizations down ranking in the
algorithm and and of course who do they
promote CNN CBS News horrible track
record horrible organizations that I
don't even call news organizations they
are propaganda organizations that have
been caught multiple times lying on
purpose
spreading disinformation hurting people
with the the misinformation that of
course they spread to the general public
and having a huge negative effect on the
general public pushing of course
partisan bullcrap rather than of course
actual news and the people who do
promote actual news we get we get hurt
by the algorithm since of course there's
this favoritism on YouTube which
evalates uh elevates those voices that
you were just mentioning so I'm curious
what everyone's thoughts are on this but
you know what do you think is the answer
to that because I mean the way I I see
it is
you know you want to diversify number
one and be available in multiple places
lots of places hopefully across many
different platforms but I also think
like you know the conservative movement
you know anybody who cares about Liberty
in this country should get invested in
creating our own platforms and our own
Tech and do everything like let us like
Mao's it let a thousand flowers bloom
try a bunch of different things but like
also build your own ecosystem at some
point for when the day comes with like
no notification notifications go out for
the show right and they totally block
the account I mean I think so and you
know part of me thinks that maybe 10
years ago five years ago maybe even that
would be you know something that would
be possible but it's gotten to the point
where the left has gone on offense so
effectively that like okay you can try
to start your own platform but they're
going to make sure that you can't Bank
anymore right you know that it's a
really good point because they get to
the root of the internet right like
we're not even just talking about like
front-end platforms now they're talking
about banking we're talking about
servers right yeah they're like your
website can't be hosted yeah you can
accept zero dollars but you can solve
that problem you know with the servers
you know you you I mean you could be off
AWS for example or whatever but the
banking part yeah really really and
they've gotten very effective at trying
that like like they're all their their
entire strategy has moved like you know
you used to be able to be a Libertarian
I think right and it made sense it was
kind of like leave me alone Live and Let
Live but at this point that's not good
enough they don't want to let live they
will will continue pushing forward so
basically at this point you're left with
nothing but like you have to fight back
and what they can't and what they can't
get done through government they get
through done through other institutions
for corporations corporations and other
left-wing entity take a look at this so
I found it on uh so I was on my phone
it's called hit pause and this is the
one of these videos was in my feed
automatically but it was like when you
when you open the YouTube app you can
see like the username the the video and
then the name of the the video or
whatever these have like had like their
own special box let me actually see if I
can
pull it up on my phone and then actually
just show you this way because it's
certainly not I don't know just I
wouldn't call it normal how it how it
popped up on my uh my feed it was two
thousand so take a look at this yeah
it's like it takes up the whole phone
there you go with a YouTube featured Can
you spot the manipulation learn more
this is not a normal normal YouTube
thing and it's happening right when the
election is going on and are are about
to kick off I mean early voting is
starting relatively soon this is YouTube
manipulating the election hands down big
sack is manipulating the election on
purpose they are interfering but you
know what not I I'm willing to bet
there's going to be like one I'll say
I'll say one maybe upwards of five
Republicans who actually say anything
and even if they do they're gonna sit
down in front of big Tech and they're
gonna be like so you're you're choosing
what can and can't be seen and they're
gonna go well you know we're trying to
combat misinformation and go oh I shake
my fist at that I'm gonna write a
sternly worded letter to you and that's
the end of it then the Republicans are
gonna lose
and that and there you go
congratulations so I think uh in terms
of the political uh Arena I think the
important part right now is we're in a
situation where Democrats have the house
the Senate the White House right we need
to take control of at least one branch
and the corporate media and the big Tech
social media and big Tech social media
so ideally in Hollywood you know and I
mean that's that's what in the music
industry I mean that's what we're up
against and the higher institutions of
learning this is getting pretty
depressing
so so the thing is is that we have to
take a majority and either you know want
the house or the senate or both
hopefully that we can get a majority and
that's when we start holding our
Representatives our Senators feed to the
fire because without having a majority
you're just you know what can you do
you're getting a railroad when a few
Hollow roles if you have the house if
you have the gavel in the house then you
have the power to investigate the power
to subpoena right and that's an
incredibly powerful thing to have so
yeah I mean getting a house majority in
particular would be very useful for
investigating some of this stuff but one
thing I would say though also I mean
like look I think the internet has been
great for Libertarians and conservatives
I think the internet is probably the
most democratizing force in politics in
the history since the printing press
right and I think there's more of us
than there are of them and so the
internet is obviously a place where
finally we get to rebalance the teams
right the corporate media is never going
to give us an equal share but on the
internet we have a chance I think the
big problem that we have with big Tech
or you know
you know any any of this stuff this the
shadow Banning and everything is they're
really responding to government
incentives right because you know their
business model is let's make as much
money as we can let's service many ads
to people as we can let's get as many
users as we can the only thing that
threatens that is the government right
and so they're going to respond to those
incentives in a way that says I want to
work with you you know oh yeah we'll
we'll we'll regulate content the people
that you don't like you know we're gonna
Shadow ban so you're going to feel
better uh about the content that the
voters are seeing in this country but
you know if we get power
is what what's going to happen you know
are they gonna flip around and start
Banning a bunch of liberals no probably
not nope so here's the video this is
really interesting let's play this we
have it uh uh how how we're tackling
misinformation on YouTube and it's very
very enlightening check it out let me
make sure we have uh let's play let's
let me make sure we have the sound
turned on properly oh this is this is
great learn more about the topics that
interest them we have a responsibility
to increase access to good information
good information decreasing the bad to
make sure that we're doing that we
tackle misinformation on our platform
based on what we call four hours of
responsibility we remove the most
harmful content that violates our
policies we reduce recommendations of
borderline content we raise up
authoritative sources for news and
information and we reward trusted
creators and artists you can learn more
about how we enforce our policies in a
separate video but the bottom line is
that we aim to enforce our community
guidelines consistently using a com
combination of machine Learning Systems
content reviewers and user reports to
detect review and remove content that
crosses the line
we strive to remove content that
violates our policies before it's widely
viewed or viewed at all for more
information about the issue right there
is that they reduce recommendations on
what they deem to be borderline while
propping up authoritative sources
how do you become an authoritative
Source corporate power and money that's
what it always is that's why it was it
was I think like four years ago
a whole whole swath of YouTubers noticed
the recommendations collapsed from like
seven or eight percent of their views to
like point one Fox News MSNBC and CNN
shot straight up yeah yeah they're
pretty much saying hey you don't have a
billionaire corporate a millionaire you
know agenda for your cause you're
screwed sorry good luck next time well
that 4r thing was pretty horrific you
could see them break it down and the
thing is that that's actually not
unprecedented at all we saw in a
previous cycle where uh Hunter Biden's
laptop is labeled misinformation or
propaganda from like over from a Russian
propaganda machine and so those
so-called authoritative sources are the
ones who agreed like almost like a
cartel of information that like we will
not cover this at all we're not going to
highlight that so when they say
authoritative sources are they going to
hold accountable to people who told us
two years ago that this is a Russian
misinformation or the hunter Biden story
or or the Hillary Clinton Russia gate or
wmds in Iraq right is YouTube gonna go
back and flag all the videos from The
New York Times And The Washington Post
and BuzzFeed all on the russiagate stuff
that wasn't real yeah are those flags is
that misinformation now are all of their
their accounts gonna be blacklisted how
many strikes do those Camp do those
channels deserve like New York Times for
misinformation like those there were
four years of Trump's presidency where
it was basically one after the other
conspiracy theory that the media is
running wildly with and irresponsibly
with while trying to do everything they
can to silence it's just wild to me
we've gotten to the place in this
country where we need to preemptively
determine in in a conversation in a
debate who preemptively is correct yeah
and what is borderline content who
defines that what this is an orwellian
term that absolutely makes no sense at
all and could be interpreted in so many
different Fashions I'll tell you who
determines that it's the loudest
furthest left-wing people on that
company slack yeah who will make life a
living hell for everyone if they don't
get their way oh this borderline content
doesn't work for my own political
beliefs and biases therefore we have to
take it down even though it doesn't
violate the rules or the terms of
services or the code of conduct they're
like this the person's content is to the
right of Bernie Sanders so it is
dangerous and could kill me like
everything's always framed as being
dangerous that person hasn't left their
house exactly right there the world
socialist website called Bernie Sanders
and nationalist capitalist amazing and
that was a couple years ago so what
they're really saying is you're only one
degree to the left of Stalin Gotta Go
Gotta Go not far left enough I don't
know how much further left you can go
after that but here we are ladies and
gentlemen so my question I guess I'm
wondering here's the challenge in terms
of a lawsuit how do you know you're
being affected by it right now it's
speculation a lot of people are
reporting they're not getting
notifications they're also reporting
that the app is crashing and we've
noticed some interesting things the live
show that is completely atypical we'll
have like 40 000 live viewers and then
in 10 minutes or not even in 10 minutes
but in like one jump it'll go like 40 41
000 38 000 which it makes no sense that
3 000 people all at once all just like
decided you know what at this point I'm
turning the show off but people are
telling us it's crashing on them the
challenge is let's say we are being
negatively impacted by this and it's a
breach of contract what are the rules
did we break them how do we know
when I sign up for YouTube and I agree
to do this business and a portion of my
ad Revenue goes to them they have to
abide by their side of the bargain as
well if they're telling me now that
they're altering the terms without
without saying anything to me and I sign
an agreement they they're changing
then what can we do I mean if we Sue
that the Court's going to be a lot
YouTube's going to say it's not
happening and then I'm gonna say well I
want Discovery to see exactly how their
algorithm is is doing this and then it's
probably going to get thrown out because
the courts just always look big
corporations win that's out I mean
that's the thing is that at the end of
the day you know Google owning YouTube
is going to have an army of attorneys
who 24 hours a day will fight to ensure
that no one can ever see a lick of the
algorithm that they have that determines
any of this you know they absolutely
can't let any of that out
I mean that's the whole question is I I
think it's going to require uh the
government intervening it's going to
require Republicans to to take actually
do something well already look already
uh Alex Berenson got got an opinion from
from I think the federal court that big
Tech does not have the ability to censor
arbitrarily or something to that effect
it's huge I mean this opinion could open
the floodgates the challenge is you
still need to prove they took an action
so right now we have speculation YouTube
13 days ago said we are going to start
doing this thing recently people said
hey I'm noticing a thing on your Channel
so it's speculative what can we do to
get Discovery or anything like that we
can argue that around this time we saw a
reduction in our in our live show
viewership and that's censorship and
they might just argue now your show
sucks
and what do you say a judge is going to
be like unless you can prove something
was actually done so well maybe in
Discovery we could see hey they're
talking about limiting these in these
channels you won't even get to Discovery
unless you can say they did a thing to
damage my business in violation of a
contract
so this is the problem with big Tech
everything that Ian brings up all the
time and this is right about the one
thing I don't agree with Ian on as he
says we got to free the software code I
figure yeah if you guys have watched the
show you've heard him say it and I'm
like why why why but the when he's
talking about this just we're going to
free the code it's going to fix
everything I'm like you're wrong but
when he says we got to free the code
because otherwise you don't know what
the corporations are doing he's
completely right so I don't know if you
you know freeing the code might not
necessarily be the right thing but there
is a problem in that Facebook has been
experimenting on people and manipulating
people we got that report from The
Washington Post at their their
psychological operations targeting you
know people that it was mostly
pro-ukraine anti-russia if we don't know
what these platforms are doing they
could be doing illegal things how do we
solve for that what's the oversight
right when so you know if you want to
open a restaurant and sell cheeseburgers
you know how many permits you're gonna
get how hard it is in fact I think it's
too hard it shouldn't be that hard to
sell a cheeseburger but it's so insanely
easy relatively to manipulate the public
with algorithms made drive them insane
or push political bias
exactly I mean from the very beginning
I've always been talking about the the
intelligence agencies and their
influence on big Tech social media and I
think that's becoming more and more
apparent there's fauchy parody accounts
that are being taken down because the US
government is saying hey this is not
okay we don't like you making fun of our
Lord and savior Dr fauci hey this former
New York Times journalist bringing up
scientific facts and studies and
research we don't like that because it
goes against our agenda and they're
bending the rules of society and
screwing everyone else over providing a
huge disservice to everyone online by
limiting the amount of information that
could go into their ears in mind that to
me is god-like Authority that they are
absolutely abusing they should have
never been trusted in the first place
with this power and authority but yet
here we are today which is crazy I'll
tell you the one thing that we can do
for the time being obviously you know so
we had an issue with a News Guard you
guys familiar with the news oh yeah yeah
so uh they gave us an 82 out of 100. let
me just say YouTube your beloved Bill
Gates News Guard okay newsguard has a
deal with Microsoft you know some people
were like clarify Tim it's not Bill
Gates funding it no no they have a deal
with Microsoft it embeds the News Guard
thing I use that specifically
because it's a check against their
attacks against us it's a good insurance
policy for sure we so a good example of
how this plays out we had a I had a
legal dispute with them that was
resolved and we ultimately won to the
best of what we could win and there's no
there's no Pursuit after this but I'll
explain
they emailed me about timcast.com and
said that uh you had two stories
alleging that Hunter Biden was helping
secure funding for Bio labs in Ukraine
or something like that on your YouTube
channel how you explain this and my
response was just like
those two stories that you're talking
about were are cited by two News Guard
certified sources and they went oh yeah
sorry about that never mind so they
tried claiming falsely that the hunter
Biden laptop story was fake to me that
the emails weren't real to me newsguard
and I said newsguard certified these two
outlets who have independently verified
the emails are real
next question
so what do they do they come back and
they claim that because we quoted Trump
without fact checking him we're
irresponsible and gave us a strike
still we're at 82 out of 100 considered
green check mark we have a higher rating
than CNN MSNBC and Fox News all of those
major Outlets
but it took them about three weeks to
correct a a plethora of errors
so I came to them and I said fix the air
they said no fix the air I said no I
said if you do if now acknowledging you
know there's errors you won't fix them
I'm going to sue you they came back and
they were like you'll never win because
we'll claim all of these are opinion
except they are fact and I was just like
what ultimately what they ended up doing
they did back down on everything except
removing the strike so we remain at 82
out of 100 but they issued this
ridiculous wall of Corrections because
it was just insanely wrong but so this
is the issue I bring that up because
people have asked me about it like are
you going to sue News Guard I'm like we
won I can't right it's it's over I
talked to three different lawyers I
think and they said you won they they
issued a wall of retractions and
corrections but they're not going to
rate you better I don't think a judge is
going to get it past summary he's going
to be like you got what you wanted and
then I'd argue no they're calling me
irresponsible yeah well it's an opinion
have a nice day you're out in this
capacity what YouTube is doing we we
need to especially considering the Alex
Berenson uh opinion that came out
Chung they have no right to censor we
need to make sure we're doing everything
in our power to stop YouTube Facebook
and Twitter from deciding what is true
this should not be allowed imagine if a
T and T is the example everyone uses her
who's intercepting your phone calls and
we're like I said something I didn't
like that I didn't think was true so
they hang up on you right they can't be
allowed to do that for the time being
here's what y'all can do YouTube is
powerless against a popular show
they're completely powerless against it
they could Shadow ban the channel so
that it could only be viewed if you type
in the website URL and then we post it
on timcast.com and if you're a fan of
the show you find it they are presumably
trying everything in their power and
it's I think other people have it worse
than me don't don't get me wrong I think
you know they've been going after
Crowders like way harder than they go
after us so long as people actually like
the show actually tune in and be the
notification share the URL wherever you
can oh they'll start Banning people one
by one for sure but you genuinely cannot
stop a show that's popular when people
decide I'm going to tune in every day at
eight regardless of whether or not
YouTube notifies me so they're trying to
stop people from finding it but if
people watching it say no I'm going to
share because it's a good show they're
powerless they can't stop it I mean to
me I think what is long overdue and
what's going to be necessary is for
Congress to not be toothless for these
organizations and it's going to take a
consent decree the same way that you've
seen you know monolithic companies in
the past where the government says
you've gone too far they need to be a
consent decree on Google consent degree
uh for Twitter
um especially given that we now know and
has become widely apparent to anyone
who's willing to to see the truth that
in an election cycle
all these companies the big tech
companies the large corporate media
companies banded together and created a
cartel of information and said no voters
voters aren't allowed to know this they
regret the internet
oh yeah they didn't see it coming no
they really do they really do because
it's the biggest threat to Legacy Media
right it allows us an end Legacy yeah an
Enron around all the traditional
Gatekeepers that you see on cable news
every night to information that you can
seek yourself I mean it's the biggest
threat to their entire business model
yeah it temporarily allowed a free
market where people got to choose ideas
and and individuals and trusted
individuals that of course did their
work did their homework over of course
the propaganda but there's a lot of
cross currents in this tune this it's
just fascinating this whole debate on
Tech and the media and everything in
censorship because some of the biggest
proponents of a lot of the tech
regulations that are working their way
through Congress are the Legacy Media
folks themselves because it's a market
share thing for them they think if they
can regulate Tech more that they'll
restore their position in this you know
new ecosystem where Congress can sort of
work the refs a little bit at all the
platforms and maybe CNN gets ranked tire
and like you know people on Facebook
will see CNN's content more uh in in
their feed rather than Ben Shapiro for
example so I think we got to be really
careful here I think there's there's two
distinctions right there's putting
government more in charge of refereeing
that whole thing
and these sort of blanket things that
you said smug which I think is fantastic
where you could say look I mean if
there's a direct call to physical
violence media call physical violence
yeah I mean maybe you can censor that
but everything else fine I mean if it's
like I don't know pedophilia yeah you
can censor that but anything else it's
fine and you don't have a right to
censor anyone regardless of their
political opinion and I mean I don't
know what normal person in this country
could look at the last couple of years
and everything that we were fed you know
on covid or anything else and think
um we don't need a free market of ID
yeah we don't need a debate that lingers
for a long time that people should be
allowed to say stuff that's wrong that
people saying stuff wrong that is wrong
and not being censored for it is
actually probably healthy for our
democracy
so uh what what was the internet the 80s
like the first iteration was the early
80s
it was I'm pretty sure it was DARPA yeah
and um preliminary I don't know the
original history but uh is the
universities and and the defense
department yeah yeah and it was like hey
I need to send information for a
database really quickly or whatever so
we'll connect these computers and then
you get the early 90s and I remember
watching this video where this guy is
saying maybe you guys have seen it he's
like the internet's not going to catch
on yeah it makes no sense and they were
showing like you can buy movie tickets
just on your computer like this and he's
like no one's going to want to do that
it's too complicated and now the world
is the internet right so back then
the powers that be the Legacy not just
the media the politicians the the the
financial institutions the wealthy
Elites they were like who cares then the
internet became ubiquitous and they were
like who cares then Donald Trump won the
election and they went my god what have
we done and now since then they've been
doing everything in their power to
reverse this in 2018 we saw the
synchronized Banning of Alex Jones just
every platform all at once except for
Twitter and then Twitter waited like a
week and then got them I guess they were
like we're not doing what they're doing
psych beep wasn't there a leaked video
at Google headquarters with their
reaction to Trump's election yeah people
were crying and said why did we let this
happen and they had a town hall where
they were like okay guys it was
basically a struggle session of like we
have to do everything we can to stop him
yes okay the sun has an article talking
about how you know the videos came out
and they were plotting essentially to
stop Donald Trump's re-election after
2020. and you could see that they they
rigged the game because I think a lot of
people who helped start these big Tech
social media companies well a lot of
them are connected to of course
intelligence agencies I've been talking
about this very very long time and we
have been seeing big Tech social media
act on the beheadst of them more and
more and it's becoming more clear and
more obvious and I think they realize
that if they could control the algorithm
they could control people's perceptions
they could control people's minds and
that's a power that is extremely
addicting I think that's a power that
has influenced a lot of these major
decisions and I think what we're seeing
right now is a slow squeeze first you
got to get the radicals you got to get
the crazies you got to get the racist
and everyone's like yeah sure this crazy
guy who believes in Flat Earth or
whatever get rid of them whatever this
racist yeah get rid of them but now it's
it's individuals like Alex Jones now
it's for it's politicians now it's
scientists now it's legitimate
journalists now it's borderline content
you don't even have to violate any rules
it doesn't matter you're still getting
cut you're still not going to be shown
to anyone your career screwed over CNN
Anderson Cooper come on on in what your
CIA connections you could say whatever
you want with us we'll even do deals
with you which they did which is
absolutely crazy when we had Dr Drew on
the show this was really funny because
uh we started talking about uh the
pandemic and then all of a sudden on
YouTube side interruptions the stream is
freezing hilarious the moment we shift
and start talking about Civil War
everything's fine again then immediately
I'm like wait let's go back to the
pandemic and then starts freezing again
and I'm just like dude at this point
you're not convincing me this is a
coincidence we had someone on the show I
can't remember who it was but Luke
started talking about the CIA and then
all of a sudden the stream freezes oh
yeah and then people came back later and
they're like you know there's like a
minute missing from your show and we're
like oh gee I wonder I wonder just a big
mistake it's always just a big mistake
you know man you know what I think I
think they don't like this show I think
they like it to a certain extent we're
not as egregious or overt as a lot of
the people they could easily ban and so
creates a problem we call out the lies
we call out Joe Biden we fact check the
manipulate relations in the media
particularly with things like Russia
gate and Ukraine gate repeatedly we rag
on Barack Obama for killing kids these
things are all true and in the
mainstream press and they just really
wish these the people running big Tech
who wish Trump never won the politicians
they would they really wish that we
would just shut up and say the things
they tell us are approved to say like
Ukraine good Russia bad
I mean that's the thing is I I think
that was just such a shock to their
system when Trump won that like wait
this isn't what we had planned this
isn't someone on our team what the
hell's going on we we all agreed it was
going to be Hillary right like they were
they were so shocked and they're like
okay this is such a legitimate threat
for our ability to be able to kind of
like uh prognosticate what's coming next
and help steer it in the way that we
need it steered and so when when Trump
shows up and it's just an absolute just
it crumbles what they needed to happen
is when you started seeing these things
at Google where they're having like a
struggle session being like how do we
prevent this from ever happening again
because we don't want anything to happen
that we can't predict and control yeah
and the connections are a lot more
obvious than people think even Eric
Schmidt the former head of alphabet now
working with the weaponized information
Pentagon board by the way uh but when he
was head of alphabet he was working with
Hillary Clinton on her campaign and he
he even bankrolled a lot of the early
think tanks that came out with the term
fake news before the 2020 election I
asked them about this I was like don't
you see this as a huge bias as you
starting and weaponizing the term fake
news and using it against predominantly
the Republicans with this larger push
for censorship when you're a part of
alphabet Google and YouTube and he ended
up cursing at me because this was also
outside of the Bilderberg meeting he
wasn't very happy about that and I had
to you know tell him promptly like hey
man don't curse on my YouTube video
you're going to get it demonetized let's
let's let's do this you can see that
video on my YouTube channel if you could
find it we're gonna hit two birds with
one stone with this story here from the
Indian Express I'm gonna show you how
they manipulate you and why they don't
like shows like ours the Indian Express
reports selectively zoomed in video by
Republican Twitter account shows Biden
being lost on stage after speech for
what reason is the headline of this News
Guard certified Outlet saying
selectively zoomed in video by
Republican Twitter account why don't
they just say video shows Biden being
lost on stage after his speech they
can't do it I mean if they have they
have to prime it right it's not just
it's not just the reporters people
understand like it it's the editors it's
it's the people who who write the
headlines you know you look well we used
to be straight news stories and
everything is now an editorial look at
this that News Guard is like they
actually put the logo in the store look
at that well just uh real quick I'm
gonna pull up this story from timcast so
you can all see that we here at timcast
IRL we're an opinion show but our home
base website timcast.com is also
certified by newsguard okay there all
right Indian Express
selectively zoomed in they've poisoned
the well because the reality is Joe
Biden got lost on stage and we will say
it and now they're saying oh he's saying
it again how do we get him to stop it's
simple guys just call me and offer me
the hundred million dollars already
I'm kidding they can't stop us they
can't
um we don't break the rules we try very
much to make a family-friendly show
debunking the lies and exposing this
manipulation the most important thing
here and the one thing they really don't
like is that we are outright exposing
how they're poisoning the well to make
you see this and say republican
Republican equals fake news no the
reality is there's a video outright look
at here you go let me play the video for
you and you tell me what you think I'm
not going to tell you what to think you
here's the video there you go
[Applause]
where's he gone what's he doing oh other
way no no
down oh
there we go Mr President thank you
I love that part yeah
still stuck thank you what's he doing
still stuck for all the millions what's
he doing whose lives will be saved
you're zoomed too far in Tim you gotta
zoom out what is this he's not lost
because like the camera doesn't know
what to do
yes he's lost now look he's not lost in
the sense of like where am I what
building is this he's lost in the sense
of he is confused and doesn't know
what's going on or what to do so when
you come out you're like man he looks
lost it could mean like lost in the
jungle or it could mean he doesn't know
what he's supposed to be doing right now
right and so they say it's manipulation
but look at his hands look when he walks
away from the podium what's he doing
with his Mr burn hands he he he looks
like Ricky Bobby and Talladega Nights
where he's doing that interview I don't
know what to do with my hands I don't
know what to do with my hands yeah right
but he's like what is this well I think
what's happening in that video and I
don't know for sure but it seems to me
that Joe Biden is sort of looking off
camera to some Handler in the back of
the room like what am I supposed to do
next you know because they probably
primed him for this like oh you're gonna
go up there you can give a speech and
then you're supposed to sit down or
whatever and Joe Biden just forgot
that happened he probably just doesn't
know exactly and it's not the first time
we've seen this we've seen this like
over and over and over and get again but
what like the media wants to do is like
like what are you going to believe
you're going to believe Tim are you
gonna be in your in Your Lying Eyes
you're gonna believe us look at G Prime
85 and the responses this is a man I
would follow into the trenches
so I'll tell you I'll tell you why
they're mad I'll tell you why they're
pissed because uh I had someone comment
on my Facebook and it was a moment of
lucidity a moment of honesty and Clarity
and I was I was impressed it was a
leftist and there were people saying
things like you're a grifter
and this one person said the reason we
hate you so much is because you're
shattering consensus reality yes and I
went yeah okay I I agree with that that
is an incredible compliment yeah yeah
um but in in their mind they're like
everyone must agree no matter what and
so uh I love the idea so now I'm working
on a song called consensus reality and
you know or maybe a concept album or
something but I'm like
at least they're honest but that
actually explains what's going on we see
a video of Joe Biden with his hands
confused and he's like daughtering about
confused we see videos of him reaching
out his hand to shake someone's hand but
there's nobody there and then he looks
confused we see him on stage in the
debates before he even got elected with
his teeth falling out his eyeball popped
too his eyeball popped in blood here's
the issue
you know what I care about I like Julian
Assange I care about knowing the truth
and people having the ability to make
decisions for themselves based on the
best information they can get I don't
care what you do with your life just
don't hurt other people and that's
that's the right way to go about things
let me give you information to the best
of my abilities that's accurate so you
can survive hey learn how to have
chickens learn how to have goats watch
out there might be a recession coming
all that good stuff and then you do you
I do me they don't like that because
they think
if you shed our confidence in Joe Biden
during a time of war with Russia you're
putting our efforts at risk if you come
out and question the Ukrainian
propaganda and and and don't toe the
line 100 because I don't trust Vladimir
Putin either but I'm not going to sit
here and believe all the garbage lies
they spew about Ukraine just so I March
behind War they're pissed off about it
so you know what the real issue is it's
shattering consensus reality but it's
because the consensus reality gets
people to March and locks that behind
them as they go and blow up kids and
wage war for pipelines and oil and
Conquest it's I think that's it
ultimately it's it's interesting what we
like to call it on our show is current
thing enforcers the current thing
enforcers that really and and this isn't
just the media it's it's your
run-of-the-mill liberals on the internet
now too that you know they put the right
flag at that at the right time on their
Twitter bio you know they're enforcing
the sort of lockstep thing Tim that
you're describing here and then they've
sort of made it their lives their lives
work to sort of uh attack people who
challenge that I don't know where that
comes from why people dedicate their
lives to this but it's fascinating and
it's only come in the last few years and
then you know I mean that DHS uh uh
disinformation board that Nina jankow
was remember they were going to create
that administrative truth the
governments was going to tell us you
know what the truth was they actually
tried to they actually tried to uh
institutionalize this current thing
enforcer her job was basically going to
be to be the Karen of the internet yeah
yeah so tomorrow I'm gonna see it
armored truck pull up two guys ensues
are going to walk out with a couple
briefcases and they're going to just pop
them open when they're going to be a
contract and they'll be like we agree
I'm gonna be like oh no
yeah that's the thing you know um
I can't there's something akin to uh you
guys know the the the economic hit man
what was it called Tales tells Luke do
you know this one the economic Hitman
um it was the book was called economic
Hitman
um I forgot that his name confessions
so what he said was basically you know
first they'll go to a country and say
hey do X then the person says no Then
they come back and say okay if you do X
we'll give you y then the person says no
Then they say okay we're invading you to
remove you to get someone who will do it
so it's like we want oil or we want
bananas or who knows what there's
something similar
um in in the United States with with
everything it's how it works and it's
it's not a conspiracy it's just basic
power power structures the first thing
that happens is they'll be like hey
you're doing a really great job why
don't you come work for me you say no
then they come back to you and say why
don't you come and work with this
company for a large sum of money you say
no then all of a sudden you're banned
stripped kicked out whatever they shut
you down so I really do think what we're
seeing now is
after the Banning of Alex Jones it
caused a massive ripple effect and that
had negative consequences the rise of
parlor gab mines now truth social and
they're like whoa that was bad parlor
was really scary for him yeah because
parlor was was a meteoric rise so they
colluded to shut it down that was a that
was overt like we watched that happen
that's so crazy it's right in your face
they're smart now they've got to do it
silently and slowly the strategy now I
had a guy from a former Trump
Administration guy tell me this he said
the goal is
if conservative media is effective 60 of
the time that means over a long enough
period of time Democrats lose so what
they need to do is hobble the
conservatives only by 11 to put them at
49 so that Democrats hit 50 and overtime
Democrats win so they're avoiding now
the hardcore overt Banning they're doing
it very very slowly to create a
narrative like oh Crowder got a strike
because he did this then they're going
to wait then they're gonna every time
they give them a strike they're knocking
them off YouTube for two weeks and that
is effective a lot of people are saying
stuff like why don't you go to rumble
well rumble's great but I'll tell you
this Their audience is very very much
one con one demographic YouTube has gen
Z that's why YouTube is very much like
we gotta shut this stuff down
that's the game they're playing slow
slow attrition yeah Confessions by an
economic Hitman a great book by John
Perkins and in the book he detailed
exactly how the IMF the World Bank were
working with U.S Intel agencies to
extort coerce and manipulate developing
countries for the benefit of an
unaccountable ruling corporate banking
Elite so he talks about invested
interests of governments not working for
the benefit of the people but working
for the benefit of the people who put
them in charge and that of course are
the special interests and the big powers
that of course are there behind the
scenes and of course these same powers
are obviously doing the same thing
understanding that now on the internet
people have a lot of power people have a
lot of influence they want that power
they want all that influence and they're
going to do anything and everything just
to make sure that they have a monopoly
on it and then you see you see other
countries see that model and and put
into effect themselves like China with
Belton Road they're like huh it's kind
of like a Monster yeah it's kind of it's
kind of like the mafia Tim to your point
of like you know how are they changing
their strategy and in this it's it's not
just the outright bands it's more like
the mafia walking into your your
restaurant and saying wow nice place you
got here be shame if anything would have
happened to it yes you know I couldn't
help but notice just selling that uh
chicken I sell chicken too maybe you
should sell beef and you're like I don't
want to sell beef okay and then he pulls
out the Crowbar and says I'm gonna I'm
gonna say it again maybe you should sell
the beef and then you're like it's like
get in line and sell it which one what
we want you to sell or else yeah I do
think it's funny though and and you know
I don't know your guys's backgrounds
like where do you guys come from what's
your background
um I'm from Indianapolis originally
um love the Midwest not for what about
you born in Denver raised in the South
North Carolina but you guys you do you
come from Silver Spoon families and
trust funds and Ivy Leagues and all that
stuff nope no I mean my family's I'm
very proud to be a state college grad
and have Ivy Leaguers work for me oh no
I I I went to IU go Hoosiers so I I
think that's like that kind of hits the
nail on that with the hammer why they
don't like us for the most part so over
the summer we had a total of I think
like 24 Billboards yeah 24 I shouldn't
say Billboards but uh on on three
separate Billboards 24 ads in Times
Square for a bunch of our projects we
got a big old Michael malice Lou
gradkowski Ian Crossland me up on these
massive Billboards I had a big vinyl one
and it really triggered a lot of these
people to see us in their space like
right above the ABC building but I bring
this up because
I asked Luke like what do your parents
think did they ever think that you
running and chasing after a Rothschild
would result in him getting a billboard
in Times Square 95 feet tall and that's
kind of the point he's not supposed to
the Rothschilds I mean who else kiss
history uh Ben Bernanke these powerful
Elites are like this guy this this salt
of the earth dude challenging me and the
things I do is not someone who's
supposed to be standing next to me on
top of the mountain and at some point
for some reason they lost control and
here we are and now they're like uh oh
and that's the thing is is there is a
class that thrives on predictability
that it absolutely for them to maintain
what they have I mean you see right now
it's become crystal clear that there is
absolutely an academic Coastal
University class of individuals who
demand that the world exists in the way
that they want and and if you have any
sort of a Viewpoint which imposes that
you're a bigot you need to be silenced
you're danger you're a domestic
terrorist and and an extension of this
is whenever they they see something that
did not go how they planned it and
doesn't ensure that the boat is not
rocked I mean goes right back to Trump
getting elected it just outrages them
and and seeing the swing back like the
amount of of of of force that they
brought to bear against Trump is
unprecedented when a former president
can get kicked off of social media I
mean that's that's got to be stunning I
mean they decide they decided because
Hillary Clinton lost an election they
would break the internet or or try to I
mean that was the the temper tantrum
that they threw after 2016. are you all
familiar with uh debt internet Theory no
no no I I think it's it's probably
partially true to a certain degree it's
the idea that around 2016 the internet
slowly transformed into a completely
astroturfed platform where very few real
people actually exist and I think that's
probably true
I think there's probably verified
individuals then uh the reason I think
it's probably true is because whenever I
go to events I meet people regular
people and they're just like oh I'm
banned from Twitter so I can't follow
you and I'm like
really why what happened like I don't
know I had 300 followers and they expand
me and I'm like really I'm wondering if
at some point there was a real concern
with regular people being able to
organize online particularly look you
look at the Arab Spring then trumps
Victor and they went oh it can happen
here yeah so I think to a certain degree
it's the NPC and internet they've
created the NPC no exactly yeah that's
why when Elon Musk was like I'm gonna
buy Twitter all of the right-wing voices
and libertarian moderate type saw huge
gains yeah and all the left and
celebrities dropped dramatically that
was the fake reality these these leftist
personalities these leftist politicians
and celebrities had fake followers
because that was the approved consensus
reality and when they thought Elon Musk
was coming in they panicked and then
something got reversed overnight yeah
it's it's like when your parents gonna
come home you got to clean your room
really really quickly
Let's uh let's do this let's do another
segment exemplifying exactly why they
want us censored from The Daily Mail
exclusive Hunter gone wild unhinged
videos show the president's son dancing
shirtless slipping down a water slide
naked and entertaining hookers at
debauched pool party in 4 140 per night
Malibu rental wasn't the government
paying for that yeah to your service as
well Secret Service they were
hey man he's living his best life
so the one thing I'm gonna defend Hunter
here
one on one thing they show a clip of him
in jeans with no shirt on making eggs
and he's like dancing as he does it and
I'm like
this is pretty normal yeah Lydia said it
was like the least objectionable thing
is just like us
[Music]
see this is the kind of thing that makes
them panic when you expose there's
another story which is probably more
important that Hunter Biden's being
accused of work working or being a
um under the control of foreign
influence like that's the real story and
so actually they're probably more happy
for us to talk about Hunter going wild
and you know I don't know just living
his best life with group sex because
that when they can try to make the story
that conservatives mad Hunter lives
salacious life yeah they can completely
distract from well he was doing a lot of
of negotiations and offering access to
his dad for a lot of money yeah they
want to make it a tabloid story when the
the truth is Joe Biden said I don't know
if people remember this Joe Biden said
you know I had no knowledge of Hunter's
business dealings at all and then all
you know the leaks come out of all the
emails emails of of you know he's gonna
meet with uh with Biden's uh business
partner on a trip over to China and then
the uh and then the other uh emails of
Hunter Biden setting up the family
office in Georgetown where he he's going
to need keys for Joe Biden and his his
Chinese business partner and it's like
has anyone asked Joe Biden why he lied
about whether he had knowledge of Hunter
Biden's business dealings he obviously
did but instead of of talking about that
we're now redirected onto this tabloid
stuff it's fascinating yeah
yeah and he was wanking down on camera
okay
claiming that like he can't support uh
the child that he had with a with a
stripper that Joe Biden refuses to
acknowledge the grandchild that is wild
that's in that's amazing I think the
whole story also goes down to the
relationship that Biden has with his
family I think there's a lot of
contention there especially with the
latest kind of diary that also has been
collaborated by the federal authorities
that also have a lot of serious
questions I think uh at the end of the
day there was a lot more to this
father-son relationship that is very
Troublesome that I think is worth
investigating more as well because if
you truly look at Biden I mean there's
so many instances where you could say
holy cow this this this is leading down
a pathway of something very dangerous of
something very nefarious of something
really nasty and bad that I think we're
still only scratching the surface of and
as we're investigating every little
detail about Donald Trump's private life
I'm so glad you said that because it's
absolutely fascinating that we're
talking about a a court case in New York
on Donald Trump and the raid of
Mar-A-Lago meanwhile you know the
current president United States is son
selling access to his office we've all
we know all this stuff to be facts now
and there's no investigation in Congress
right now on any of that stuff but I
know that Republicans have said and
they've promised if we retake the house
that they're going to subpoena people
and we're gonna start to have
investigations on this I really hope
that they do and I mean the greatest
irony to me is that like you hear case
after case that's in filed against Trump
all the allegations that the media was
told to go and report on all these
things that Donald Trump did in Russia
well actually the hunter Biden was doing
all all along while arranging deals with
the vice president of the United States
to capitalize on this and when they talk
about oh Donald Trump must be
compromised there's all this compliment
meanwhile the the president's son is
doing a lot of mad stuff while setting a
business this is it's it's a censorship
and stuff like this that makes me want
to vote for Trump more than ever yeah I
I really do think DeSantis would be
better I really especially with the
Martha's Vineyard thing well that was
brilliant it was it was genius it was it
was a master stroke but uh but Donald
Trump just I understand why people so
many people were like he's gonna come in
and just kick the door in on the
establishment and uh knowing how much
they despise and fear Him
when they do stuff like this when they
lie cheat and steal when they censor and
scream like little whiny babies having a
temper tantrum I'm like all right fine
get Trump just bring Trump in geez you
know I was willing to give you a
DeSantis at the very least but then you
said he was worse all right then I'll
give you your worst fear no room for
compromise you know I tried that I was
like hey maybe you know maybe we'll
we'll find a good Democrat and then
you're just no you know what just
sending Trump and then let Trump do
whatever he wants I didn't care at this
point I think you know if Trump does run
again I think the one issue he's gonna
run into is if he centers his campaign
around 2020 and the personal politics oh
yeah grievance and that sort of thing I
just I don't think it's going to
resonate with Republicans the same way
as when he was coming down you know the
golden escalator and was saying I alone
can fix it because a lot of people
believed I alone can fix it but now he's
been president and he's going to have a
record that he accomplished or didn't
accomplish while he was president and
there's going to be other people on
stage age attacking that and of course
um I speaking on behalf of all women
everywhere they view DeSantis as dreamy
and attractive and they would vote for
him over or Donald Trump any day so uh
DeSantis is a real path to Victory
because he's gonna get all those ladies
hot and bothered but I think I mean why
do Santa's just having a lot of success
right now is because he's he's fighting
on the issues that animate the
Republican base yeah right he saw recent
polling in Florida six months ago Trump
was above DeSantis and I see desantises
DeSantis is talking about he's putting
up dubs and Trump's talking about else
yeah it's as simple as that that's right
and there's a lot to criticize on Donald
Trump especially with his record when he
was in office there's a lot of things
you could point to especially even as a
conservative a republican being like
yeah that was not a smart decision that
was not a good move I don't want to get
into it here because I'll be talking for
a while uh but but DeSantis also is
being attacked very severely the
corporate media came out and they all
called him a kidnapper today they all
call them a human trafficker when of
course he did what essentially the Biden
Administration has been doing from
months shipping migrants all across the
United States but when he does it for a
political reason he's now being labeled
he's now being sued he's going to be
dragged into court just like Donald
Trump has just like Alex Jones has and
he's being sued by an activist
organization that of course receives
money from a George Soros fund that is
connected to the open Society Network
and of course he's going to have more
legal battles now and I think there's
this is something important to note here
because a lot of the major opponents
against the current establishment all of
them are pretty much in court right now
and I don't think that's a coincidence
well this is a bit of a hobby horse for
me is that the issue of left-wing dark
money where you have billionaires you
have a a Swiss billionaire hand York
this right who funded uh uh these
various left-wing groups and this is an
overseas billionaire this is a foreign
National foreign National who's spending
hundreds of millions of dollars here in
the US he's given over 3 million Stacey
Abrams over 16 million to Joe Biden to
influence what he wants to happen so so
these groups are allowed to exist
outside of of of of normal politics in
the sense that they don't have to report
the Russians the Russians spend a
hundred thousand dollars on Facebook ads
and and the Hillary Clinton the
Democrats want to break the internet
because of that fact and this Swiss
billionaire can spend hundreds of
millions of dollars impacting our
elections and the media is like well you
know what it's for a good cause and it
goes and it goes to all these left-wing
groups that that there are various
things like uh demand Justice who
basically wants to just pack the Supreme
Court so there is no matter what they
can do you know there's still one body
in this country that has to follow the
Constitution that's the Supreme Court
and that just enrages them to no end is
that wait we thought if we control the
media and and we control you know big
Tech and we control Hollywood that means
that like everyone had to listen to us
why is the Supreme Court not falling we
want so they now have this left-wing
group pushing to pack the Supreme Court
and you see like so many groups uh
whether it's uh uh these like fake news
left-wing agencies oh yeah who try to
decide what is truth what is false it's
all funded by the same like uh open air
Society all the left-wing groups are all
funded by these billionaires Arabella
advisors remember that name the umbrella
organization that feeds cash down to all
of these groups in this fake News
Network that the left left wing has
created through couriers Newsroom and
State's Newsroom and all of these you
know the Michigan Advance is just this
it's this Michigan you know local media
thing and actually it's funded by George
Soros and this entire network and it
pushes left-wing propaganda the news
feeds of Americans every single day but
you know the thing that's interesting is
like you look at the left the the left
uh Wing you know dark money folks who
are like financing things like this
DeSantis uh the the lawsuit against
DeSantis you know where is the lawsuit
for all the migrants who died in the
back of that boxcar in Texas that
sheriff didn't care about that at all
did he no no
you know the same in the same county
where apparently these migrants come
from and he's freaking out this this
Democrat elected Sheriff what about the
story was 53 I think right yeah yeah
they were just locked in and died 102
degrees and that wasn't a big story for
them these people are well it's it's not
you know it's it's not a big deal
because it didn't happen in Martha's
Vineyard you know I mean these the the
coastal Elites who run our media only
care about places like Martha's Vineyard
they don't care about the Border they
don't care about the reality that
millions of Americans have to live you
know live under when you have to absorb
million now millions of we're breaking
records millions of people coming in
across the border you know the schools
are overwhelmed the social services and
they can't take care of 50 migrants in
the Beach Community that's the thing
yeah you have the coastal Elites who are
who they show up to like their various
book parties and everything they have to
let each other know I'm a good person
which means I you know I support uh
Sanctuary cities and in this house we
believe yeah put the yard Side Story
cities because they never have to live
with the consequences of their beliefs
that they wish to impose on the rest of
us just the same way that they they're
willing to take private jets and demand
everyone else eat worms you know like
it's the exact same situation where now
they're having to live with the
consequences of their beliefs that they
want imposing everyone else and like
whoa to even take two days before like
the military needs to get these people
out of our vacation area right now
so I'm gonna give a shout out real quick
before we move on to the next segment
someone had a really good idea they said
that I should set up an email address
where people can email so that we can
compile evidence of Shadow Banning and
use that in any potential lawsuits so if
you as a viewer of timcast have
encountered any suspected Shadow Banning
or strange anomalies email shadowband
timcast.com that's Shadow
b-a-n-n-e-d at timcast.com with
screenshots and an explanation I
understand for a lot of people it may it
may some people make mistakes and how do
you how do you send a screenshot of not
getting a notification and then they can
always argue like well we don't always
have notifications for everything but
people are saying it's a new phenomenon
but some people are pointing out they
can't comment that the videos are being
listed as as children's videos so they
can't interact at all which is just
insane and not and like not the case on
our end so they're clearly strange
happenings and I suppose the argument is
if we could compile enough of this and
show a pattern occurring among our
viewers we we may be able to at least
convince a judge something discernible
is happening and we should have a review
as to what I I don't know I talked to a
lawyer but I suppose if we can show a
pattern of activity then YouTube would
have to do a review or we'd be able to
get Discovery on any Communications
about restricting our show do you have
multiple Wi-Fi's here with different IP
addresses
I'm not going to talk about it okay well
I'm just saying I mean the video
evidence is the best evidence in theory
theoretically you could like you know
post a video and this notification will
go out and on a separate screen have you
know set up somebody as a subscriber and
try to see if you can catch it that way
and that's one way to do it I mean oh
well I'll tell you this right now for
the past couple of weeks we've had this
phenomenon where when I launched the
live stream we create a special little
thumbnail like you got you know before
before the show uh I'll I press record
and we have a staring contest because
we're basically lining up this thumbnail
for some reason and it's thanks to Ian
for for catching this the thumb the the
video for IRL is just a gray box with
with nothing in it and so that is I
believe intentional because what happens
is people will be scrolling YouTube and
they see a gray box because the
thumbnail is what attracts people and
they just scroll past it and so you know
why is this happening why did all of a
sudden randomly our thumbnails just stop
appearing to me on my end I see the
thumbnail I I pull up my account I go
over I see the thumbnail I wonder if
this is for people who are passive like
if you're a passive viewer if you're not
subscribed if you watch regularly you're
just seeing a gray box that that I think
is it has been a huge detriment and I
think it's intentional well the power
that these companies can wield using
algorithms and their technology to get
the outcome that they want is is
unbelievable I saw this uh research
paper that a gentleman did where uh he
went to China he purchased a phone there
he signed up for a tick tock account and
then he saw what kind of videos is
recommending and all the videos over
there were like the Triumph of the
Chinese people and like look at all
these like amazing things we're building
these massive Bridges educational videos
nationalistic videos and then and then
he came to back to the US he purchases
the same model phone the same model
phone signs up for a tick tock account
all he sees is teenagers talking about
like I have mental health issues and
like left-wing causes and anything that
can make you feel more depressing and
scared and debauchery and twerking Bingo
yep let's jump to this next Story
another reason why they don't like US
Air Force gender inclusive training
tells Cadets to not use Mom and Dad well
I'm confident we're going to defeat
Russia on this upcoming world war three
how about you guys well I mean that's
what I'm thinking is that it you look
back to World War II you know the Battle
of the Bulge you've had these like
massive tank battles there had to have
been a time when you know before our
shot is fired everyone hops out of the
tanks and says okay what are your
correct pronouns that's how it works I
remember that I watched an old uh War
documentary about D-Day and actually
before they even fought the the you the
U-boats like land everybody walks out
peacefully shakes hands and the
Americans ask the Germans their pronouns
they all agreed that they went back in
the boats backed up and then stormed the
beach
it's true 100 I mean I I have to be
honest like if if the reality of future
warfare was arguments I'd be okay with
that I'd prefer that actually because
you know War sucks and so if like boats
crash land on the beach and they run out
and they're carrying like you know
plushies and then they romped each other
and they're like you smell you smell
dude and that's like all war was I think
that's an improvement honestly like at
this point I think something that you
know we've seen from the past 20 years
when it was the US engaged in the global
war on terror and then
um I I think the Syrian conflict was a
great example is you're seeing less and
less of uh you know large World actors
the United States major Powers China
trying to engage in actual like
open Warfare right they'll they'll
they'll fund aside they'll arm aside but
they don't want to necessarily get
entangled in the conflict themselves
like uh I think prime example is you
bring up a China and Taiwan people like
oh my God when's China gonna like have
their ships hit the hit the beaches of
Taiwan and storm it and well I mean I
think China's it's become pretty clear
to them that we can just strangle
countries at this point with economic
might you know like what's the need to
have to invade America when we can use
Amazon to make this country dependent on
us yeah Amazon's the creepiest thing
ever it's incredible if if you were
gonna come to me and and talk about some
kind of nightmare dystopian future and
then tried claiming the neural link and
all that stuff and I bet yeah yeah you
know maybe who knows but if you come to
me and tell me that you know if a guy
came to me and said he was from the
future a nightmare dystopia with
Terminators and everything and they're
all run by Amazon I bet yeah it makes
sense yeah you know because Amazon's a
creepy company just that it's just the
control they have the way they're
destroying mom and pop shops and small
businesses we really are moving towards
this world where
I don't know how to describe it techno
communism yeah maybe just want to
describe it you're you're going to get
Ubi from the government you're going to
go on Amazon and you're going to you you
have eight you have 1800 credits per per
month to select an item it's like I
believe I'll choose this blue well
that's the thing is like when Yang ran
on the on the Ubi thing you know what
I'm surprised more people didn't
question is okay if you create this
dependence on making sure that like okay
I will get this you know Dole from the
government the next step for them then
becomes what if you do something that
displeases me you know what if your
social score or social credit score goes
down right we're going to cut how much
money you get and you're gonna have to
be hungry and maybe that'll teach you a
lesson of what happens when you don't
follow the regime's orders yeah it's
it's a carbon social credit score it's
what the world economic forum is talking
about they literally just wrote in an
article bragging about how everyone
complied with the lockdowns which means
the next climate change lockdowns are
more likely to be complied with as well
that's literally did you see a lot of
these people did you see the uh the
power companies I think it was in Nevada
maybe California as well that was
sending notifications during the
blackouts and and the heat waves that
they were sending out notifications on
the thermostat smart thermostats in
people's houses saying I'm sorry but you
can't turn down this was uh Denver I
believe yeah and and it was because they
opted into a pro like an energy program
yeah that's how it all starts that's
right and that's the thing is just opt
into the government program will help
take care of you no but but what happens
is you're getting it installed and the
guy goes would you like to opt into our
energy saver program what does that mean
means you get 100 bucks per year off
your bill they go sign me up and they
scroll through the terms of service they
don't read and they click check and then
next thing they know they can't turn the
air conditioning on and the thing is
that when they said that amount they're
like okay it'll take 100 off or 20
months I can't remember how much they
offered uh for these people to join the
energy saver program who's gonna be the
most incentivized to opt in for people
right well I mean you think I'm gonna
give up my exactly the pores yeah
a rump
that's how they live man they want their
private jets I like all the private jets
flying into the climate change Summit
yeah yeah the real meeting is them going
like how do we keep this going we gotta
stop the poor people that's exactly it
the poor people don't deserve
refrigerators or or clean water or
showers y'all can have cold crickets and
cold showers because I ain't giving up
my steak I imagine that's what Bill
Gates is saying and I mean like I've
always said is that to a certain extent
they want to say you have to eat the
bugs not because it's ecologically sound
but because they'd like to be able to
show their power like if you can make
your enemies or your subordinates eat
bugs it's like what won't it's like the
poop water they want you to drink the
poop orders or the sewage water and
there was an article did you guys see
California is going to allow composting
of humans yeah and uh the funny thing is
yeah it's terrific into soil now hold on
hold on it's not immediately bad but
there are some concerns the idea is that
you can be cremated you can be embalmed
or whatever or you can be dropped into
this vat you know of dirt and every you
get turned into dirt right it doesn't
immediately mean they're going to use
the dirt for food the soil I should say
because it's going to be fresh human
compost soil in I think Colorado I'm not
sure they ban the sale of the soil for
uh food for human consumption but
questions then are is the soil being
transferred to farms for grain for cow
consumption right to what degree are you
okay with eating former human like is it
if a corn grows from the human is then
eaten by a pig are you okay eating that
I've seen The Lion King uh the circle of
life I know how this story ends we will
be eating the human soil that's right we
will yeah yeah it's only a matter of
time especially with the food shortages
and everything going on Soylent Green is
people man have you guys seen that movie
Elysium no I didn't see that no it's
like I think it's Matt Damon yeah and
it's like everyone there's like a
utopian like layer and then there's yeah
it's a big space for it and all the rich
people live up there and then like they
have the cure for cancer and the poor
people lived on earth they all speak
Spanish and the rich people speak French
I thought it was kind of funny they got
it wrong though what's what's really
what it really should have been is all
the poor people on Earth working eating
crickets and everyone up in the Big Ring
are trafficking children
[Laughter]
no what they do and I wonder if one of
the reasons they want to shut down like
channels like this is because we will
call them out and they're probably
thinking imagine what we could get away
with I actually uh here's what I think
happens you get it's like imagine it's
10 years ago
and Epstein's on his Island sitting
there smoking a cigar next to his
picture of Bill Clinton address and
there's like this 18 year old kid who's
in he's a newbie in the whole
trafficking kids thing you know a new
recruit and he goes
you know kid before the internet nobody
knew we were doing this
now it's like I had to have a run in
with the FBI then 2020 comes along as
kids now you know a bit older and he's
like man what how much fun how cool
would it have been back in the 60s when
no one knew you were committing
atrocities against children right I
think these people know this and they're
and they're really talking about like
when we were younger nobody knew we were
doing it no journalist was allowed on
the island anybody who tried to write
about would be ridiculed or we would
simply go to the boss of the company and
say do not write it and they would look
at ABC news with that Amy rorback woman
yep she said we had this guy dead the
rights like and Clinton and here's the
thing that's why they don't like project
Veritas oh yeah I was talking to a guy
and and I passively bring up Veritas he
goes ah but they're they're all lying
you know and then I was like what do you
lie about and he was like well I don't
know I read somewhere and I'm like no
I'll tell you what James O'Keefe got
leaked this video exposing Epstein and
boy were they pissed so I'm willing to
bet they pulled out all the stops of
their billions of dollars trying to fame
that guy and he was like well all and I
was like do you think these Elite petos
who are private islands you think they
wouldn't spend at least a million
dollars lying about somebody and he's
like well
oh yeah I don't know or covering up
their traces and their tracks uh Bill
Gates literally funds the corporate
media he gives hundreds of millions of
dollars to many corporate media outlets
and of course this buys him favor this
buys him PR this buys him marketing and
and this is why Jeff his business Jeff
Bezos owns the Washington Post yeah and
when uh Bill Gates was asked about apps
well he's dead now anyway what did he
say is that what he said something like
that something like that yep yep it
doesn't matter he's dead at this point
at this point why does it even matter
you know the quote he was like well he's
dead so yeah gee he looks over Hitler
and she's like I did my job
someone needs to do a compilation of
those two videos
yeah send it to me please immediately on
Twitter I may hire you at Luke we are
changing uh but look it's a fun it's a
fun ride while it lasts I suppose the
the October surprise whatever it's going
to be they need to stop shows like this
from being able to call it out you know
whatever they end up doing with with
framing Maga or Trump or whatever
we had a guy in North Dakota just kill a
kid a teenager you know I'll call him a
kid who's 18 years old ran him down ran
him over he was drunk too this guy was
charged with the DUI he was over the
legal limit hit this kid and then claim
the kid was threatening him I'm like oh
the 18 year old kid was threatening you
and your SUV when you ran him down sure
bro you could have left so they don't
like when we call that out because they
want the narrative to be like the FBI
whistleblowers are pointing out that
it's a bunch of Maga extremists but the
reality is we got antifung BLM who've
destroyed cities across this country a
couple years ago and like yeah there are
some creepy weirdo right-wingers that
and and there's some really extreme
stuff that's happened around the world
but the overall Terror and high numbers
comes from the left hands down and
they're desperately trying to lie about
it and they play dirty games like the
ADL claims that like
so we're saying if you're
anti-government you're right wing and
it's like so like an anti-fuck
streamists could be like I'm
anti-government they go well he's a he's
a right-wing anti-government guy and
it's like bro the guy's got a communist
tattoo on it not he's anti-government
anti-government is right wing I mean
it's something how we had a summer in
this country where in the 30 largest
cities in in this nation you had
synchronized riots
synchronized riots right and then New
York State's a perfect example where
they just blanket pardoned everyone it's
like oh what you set fire to a building
what you you destroyed people's homes
their businesses their livelihoods
there's a blanket pardon I mean it's
incredible it's incredible and the way
that it's like well I mean the riots the
voice of the unheard when it smokes on
artifact right I mean it's incredible
it's incredible and they bail them out
and they raise Kamala raises money to be
like well let's get them out and you had
recidivists you had people who got out
from there committed assault and rape
after Kamala called for like cash to be
sent just here's what you do next time
there's gonna be like a protest we just
need like 500 people to join antifa no I
mean it because it's all about it's all
about the mob right if there's going to
be like a hundred people at an antifa
thing and they're all wearing hoodies
and stuff and then we're like okay we'll
get 500 people those 500 people can be
like we vote not to throw the brick then
they're gonna be like uh someone will
throw it and then the other end will be
like you're a fascist so basically you
like if you go in there and you're like
yeah I'm on board with this antifa thing
the moment you see someone trying to get
violent or doing whatever call him a
fascist being like hey let's play the
game too and then stop them from doing
it stop the violence stop the right stop
the the hurting of innocent people and I
don't know what are they going to do
about it then the media will be like
antifa stops violence within their own
race exactly as long as it's not
happening how responsible yeah you know
but fiery but mostly peaceful protests
yeah well they're like well their names
are anti-fascist guys that's right come
on
you're the bad guys we're the good guys
we like good things you like bad things
that was Sheamus's bit shout out to
Sheamus oh yeah Sheamus because his bit
was that Democrats will be alike we want
good thing yeah we we want good thing
for everyone and then you'll go okay
well how do you pay for a good thing you
want bad thing yeah you want bad thing
exactly well they're they're all down
dude it is very interesting just I feel
like it's just in like the last five
years maybe in the beginning of trump it
went from like we disagree on policy to
if you don't want this policy you're for
violence or you're killing people oh
look at Matt Walsh he's like Matt Walsh
comes out and he's like Vanderbilt
Medical Clinic is doing surgeries on
minors and then they go you're trying to
kill people that's the thing is they
they're down there that's now become the
first card that they pull is that if you
disagree with me people will die you're
advocating for violence I'm just
imagining like here's a bit for you
Sheamus if you're listening it can be
like the day a day in the life of a
left-wing activist and it's like hey
guys uh what do you want to get for
dinner I vote pizza I want wings well I
don't know if I want wings if you
disagree with me we'll die
it's just like uh okay dude calm down
you can understand why there is so much
left-wing violence when they truly
believe those are the stakes right yep
and if those are the stakes and and you
know the the rest of this machine sort
of Stokes that fire
if they really believe those are the
stakes what's the end of that I mean
that wouldn't that wouldn't be worth it
this is it is you you get you get a left
Winger to murder a kid right that's this
guy you get the Bernie Sanders supporter
gunning down those lawmakers on the
baseball diamond so you certainly do
have like creepy Ultra Ultra National
traditional traditionalists who have
committed atrocities for sure but what
you see of with with Tara from the left
is extended and what I refer to as like
blunt force or low tier right so you
know every couple of years or so you
might hear a story about some like
unhinged quote-unquote right-winger guy
and what I mean by that is like probably
like an ultra traditionalist or
nationalist who will shoot a bunch of
people it's terrifying we don't we want
that to stop the FBI should be tracking
those people and stopping that's what
they should be doing but what you get
with the left is like on a daily basis
people getting punched in the head
shoved attacked uh Benny Johnson just
had his Podium kicked over by an
unhinged lunatic uh now it's starting to
get more serious where this guy AI North
Dakota Rams a kid and he was drunk and
I'm just imagining you know maybe it's
my bias but I'm imagining this guy is
seeing this kid and they're having a
dance party and he thought the kid was
part of a republican extremist group
like what is that even but the fact that
he even thought being a part of a
republican group made the kid extremists
in some way he was paranoid and
delusional and drunk and so he killed a
kid
that's that's that's
whatever you want to say it's getting
crazy around the president of his
country had just appeared on TV not too
long ago with this like horrific red
background saying that Republican
extremists are going to destroy
democracy right and then on a daily
basis he sees left Winger left-wing
groups left-wing individuals say if you
disagree with us that's violence like
don't you realize by by showing that
this group in Vanderbilt said that this
is a profitable Enterprise that people
are gonna die that like there's gonna be
death threats don't you realize that
disagreeing with me is violence they say
they say if Republicans get back in
power that democracy is over yeah if you
truly believe that what and what you
know what doesn't justify well we're not
a democracy but if the Democrats retain
power the Republic is over that's right
so you know I see a lot of conservatives
actually saying that on Twitter I'm
being a tad bit facetious that's the
point but I'm sure they'll take it out
of context anyway but uh there's a fair
point when you see the doj being
weaponized and going after Trump
supporters and and Biden doing this
stuff that
you know what
the Democrats aren't wrong if the
Republicans win their democracy is over
that's what they call it they said when
they say our democracy they ain't
talking about you they're talking about
them and the cult and they have their
weird little system and we have a
republic that has stood since 1776
technically longer if you want to talk
about American culture not developed and
they want to end that if we want to
preserve it
yeah they're quote-unquote democracy
whatever whatever it is they're actually
doing their cult that that cult can't be
allowed to persist and it's very clear
that they do want to destroy that way of
life that they actively see it when they
describe America to them it's an
irredeemable fascist state that requires
this like complete new order to come in
what they hate is representative
democracy are Republic they hate that
what they want is a controlled system of
Elites this collusion between you know
Tech and the Intel Community doj the
media the bureaucrats who have been
there 40 years they want to be able to
control all of that and be accountable
to no one and that's what Donald Trump
was so great at and I think
we may be seeing the end of the Republic
and moving in a direction similar to
Rome with the launch of a true Empire
which hopefully won't be the Deep state
but I don't know I you know we've talked
about the fall of the Roman Empire and
how this is very similar to it and I'm
like maybe it's the the fall of the
Roman Republic actually into the Empire
but we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends we are being censored my uh my
friends thank you so much for for
watching the show and supporting us but
we're getting tons of messages from
people saying like YouTube's not
recommending it comments aren't being
allowed tons of people saying their
super chats are being blocked and I
think that I think we can see it too
that's the line well the one thing you
can do to support us is become a member
at timcast.com because ain't nothing
they can do about that we use parallel
economy which was co-founded by Dan
bongino and his censorship resistant
nothing's perfect but it's one layer of
Defense so when you become a member at
our website you are using a Dan bongino
company which is good news and it
protects us it helps their company grow
it helps our company grow and if you're
super jets ain't going through you can
do that 10 bucks a month you'll get our
uncensored show coming up at 11 PM but
also be the notification share the show
because if people choose to watch the
show recommendations censorship
meaningless if every day people say I
want to watch they share the link there
is nothing they can do to stop us let's
read
mimic says Tim to be fair Biden gets
lost in his own head
oh yeah it is true but that that
manifests you know that that may be sad
actually I'm imagining you know Biden's
at the podium and then like you you know
that was that movie Inside Out or
whatever where like the emotions were
people inside out yeah I'm imagining
like inside his head is a little Joe
Biden at the controls and the controls
he like spills coffee on him and he's
like no no trapped in here helping like
he's looking through the eyes of the
bumbling confused Biden and he's like oh
if only they could hear me
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says if
folks get the good word out to the
public they deserve that respect maybe
Gibson go him like with uh project
Veritas more folks need to speak out go
team that's the FBI agent of course
couple of them yeah definitely I think
we gotta we gotta we gotta figure this
one out I'd love to have these guys I'd
love to have these guys on the show if
they're able to that would be that'd be
awesome
because I think there I think I'd be
willing to bet the majority of FBI
agents are good but the brass is bad Tom
brass I'm skeptical of all of them but
that's just no I I'm skeptical of the
system I think people typically get into
law enforcement for good reasons but how
can you truly be good in a system that's
dysfunctional you know what I mean and
so we saw it with cops resigning when
they didn't want to Pander to play these
games when they want to be demonized and
we're seeing it now with FBI agents
blowing the whistle being like yo that's
unconstitutional people who swore not
the Constitution I think for the most
part did it for the right reason but
when you got Bad Bosses and you don't
speak out well then you're part of it
then you're the banality of evil but
these guys speaking out quitting
resigning calling it out those are the
good ones
will wolf says this morning on my train
to work I saw an advertisement for the
selective uh for the Selective Service
in Philly well that's right if there was
going to be a war with China they would
have to draft people
hands down we're at all time low
recruitment nobody wants to be an awoke
military imagine getting drafted into a
woke military I mean and instead of
prioritizing how to fight you get
prioritized about gender pronouns
and I mean I think I I think it's a
complete like you know parallel between
what's happening in in the law
enforcement in the FBI and in the
military where the top brass the upper
echelons have all been completely
politicized and they see that the way to
advance is to agree with this regime of
like okay well why don't we just
condense power we decide what's good and
we punish anyone who makes who rocks the
boat yeah let's throw out the field the
field manual we're gonna go read white
fragility exactly that's that's how
we're going to handle things in the Army
Ian Ian bought genderqueer that book
with the graphic names in it and it's
like he makes a good point like he wants
to have it to be able to reference it to
show people and all that stuff it's just
unfortunate that it gives that person
money yeah but I mean I think it's
important like I I've tweeted out images
from that book so people realize when
when you know uh you'll see the the
headline in like New York Times or
Washington Post of where it says
Republicans Banning you know like
transgender authors book right and then
if you actually show images of what's
inside this book and the demands that it
be placed in children's libraries like
we're talking like five six-year-olds to
be seeing shown these images yeah they
they act like it's like you know Huck
Finn and yeah
very different
all right USAF Bowl says retired USAF
here many of my fellow Air Force vets
think this diversity training is an
overt psyop attempt at an asymmetric
Warfare
yep
JK says get Tom McDonald on love that
guy Tom has an open invitation that's
right uh but he's a busy he's a busy guy
we want to get him out here but uh uh
big news unfortunately everybody uh it
only reached number three
we were if we said if it reached number
one we're gonna wear suits oh thank
goodness we don't have to well I said on
the high 100 but that is a bold thing to
try and accomplish but Tom McDonald's
Riot reached number three in sales on uh
uh on Billboard so that's that's awesome
glad to hear it
we got a bunch of new music in the works
too but we got a lot of stuff we're
gonna be working on so you know it'll
come out when it comes out I guess I'm
not gonna
you know it's kind of a bummer because
we've been playing music for a long time
we used to play music on the show and so
a lot of people have requested it so I
hate to be like oh it's gonna take
another year to get anything done but
yeah that's what it is that might be
something that you consider for like uh
you know you're saying a concept album
or something is a band named Shadow band
someone actually said
wow clever that's good I'm willing to
bet that's probably like 700. at this
point it plays in the shadows
Tim Jake says Tim I resign from the dod
after 38 years of service because of the
leftist agenda that was already being
pushed 24 years experience in my
specific field was less important than
following the agenda wow grafty says
Buck the buck button my God that's right
yeah it kind of feels like we're in they
live you know with how weird the agendas
become like are there aliens secretly
you know manipulating people well I mean
that story of how they're like in the
Air Force we don't want you to say the
words mom or dad I mean that's Insidious
on a number of levels of of separating
them from family of trying to to create
this like your family is the state it's
it's you know Joe Biden is your father
now and if you look at the Falls of
Empires specifically the Soviet Union it
predominantly failed because it
prioritized ideology over Merit and I
think that's what we're doing here in
the United States so yes Falcon laser
says Luke I wore that Island Boys shirt
when I saw JP Sears in Spokane last year
I got laughs and compliments for it
everywhere I went that day yeah this is
a great way to make meet like-minded
individuals to to find people who agree
with you disagree with you I get so many
different reactions high fives I get
grunts I got someone that confronted me
because I wore an anti-atf shirt in in
town recently which was a pretty fun
interaction but what was the show is it
like shooting a dog abolished the
abolition but but you also we went to
the Frederick County Fair and a guy saw
a look and said where do I get that
shirt yeah defund the ATF yeah it's
important to to wear the t-shirts
because it's one of the few ways that a
political message can't be censored a
lot of the shirts I can't even wear on
this show because if I do the show would
get hit so the best politicalshorts.com
one of the best ways to kind of do your
lazy form of activism there have been
moments where uh like Luke's Luke will
walk in from like his trailer after work
for the show and I'm like he's wearing a
shirt and and just like I won't give any
specific example but I'll be like bro
you can't wear that are you nuts maybe
it is gonna start becoming like they
live where like in real time YouTube's
just gonna start blurring out the shirt
because it doesn't agree
all right Max Reddick says Tim I'm
watching a debate between Anna kasparian
and Dennis Prager her tactics are super
clear she Gish gallops pretty intensely
also could you get David packman on your
show he would be a good one
um the challenge with getting anyone
like David or Anna or anyone else is
that they do their own shows so I would
be saying like hey David don't do your
show come do mine yeah and that's why
it's like I can respect why getting left
pundits on the show is difficult but
it's no excuse for letting these
activists who won't come on you know
what I mean but I'll reach out to David
I've known David for like 11 years and I
think we would have an interesting
conversation
um I've had conversations with him many
times I don't believe he's honest and
one example is he published a story
where he said something
I'll keep it vague because it was a few
years ago and I messaged him on Facebook
because I've known him for a decade and
I said hey David here's the source and I
sent him a link and I'm like that was
incorrect and he just ignores it and
it's like oh come on dude you're like
when people uh tweeted me that there's
an error I'll check with timcast.com
like I tell them like we gotta fact
check everything and I'm constantly
looking to make sure and there's even
there was I'll give you an example we
published a story it said North Dakota
man admits confesses to killing teenager
for being Republican and I said we
probably shouldn't say it that way
because
what he really did was he said he killed
him and was and the kid was part of a
republican extremist group so let's make
sure we're being as specific as possible
because you know what his real reason
was in the affidavit was that he was
threatened by the kid who happened to be
a republican extremist I think that is
an admission into his motive and
everything like that but I want to make
sure that we're getting everything as
precise as possible
you take far less editorial license than
CNN and MSNBC do that's for sure you
know look I I'm I'm not in charge of
editorial at timcast.com on purpose
because I don't want to go to them and
tell them you know like what stories to
do at all however I am like a stop Gap
if I see a story and it's got a
questionable false it's like bad framing
or something I'll say hey fact check and
then often like there's been a few times
where I'm like hey guys fact check and
they go Tim you're wrong here's the
proof and I go I stand corrected my own
my only thing is if I see look if I see
CNN line I'll call them out if my
website gets something wrong if I see
Santa be wrong or anything I'll call him
out if timcast gets something wrong I'll
go right into The Newsroom but hey guys
I think you got this wrong and then let
them sort it out and you know so I will
have conversations on like editorial
policy but for the most part it's it's I
would say it's like 95 independent and
all I'm trying to do is is frame check
things one example is
I said we shouldn't say pro-life or
pro-choice because those are political
terms we should say pro-abortion or
anti-abortion like if someone's arguing
in favor of a bill that would allow
abortion their pro-abortion if they're
arguing against it they're anti-abortion
pro-life and pro-choice mean different
things to different people like even
among people who support pro-life it
could mean something slightly different
and it's amazing that like that you know
that process he described is what
basically used to be journalism and now
it's the Washington Post and Taylor
Lorenz writing something and then for
the next week there's like letter an
editorial correction editorial
Correctional correction yep Tanner
Reeves says Kyle Serafin is being
reviewed is being interviewed sorry
reviewed interviewed on The Dan bongino
podcast today was part one revealing
part two is tomorrow worth the watch
very cool shout out to Dan bongino I
wanted a show on Fox a little while ago
it was great he's a great dude and uh he
had kind words and uh yeah if we could
get this whistleblower on that would be
amazing great yeah yeah well uh anybody
who's got some connections I can I can
reach out to Dan and maybe see if we can
get that would be incredible it would be
an honor and a privilege and uh there
there are very few people I think that
do as much as Dan does in the culture
War for speech technology uh aside from
Rumble which just went public
congratulations I bought a bunch of
shares and um parallel economy he's he's
he's he's doing it he's doing it right
so that's fantastic
all right you know I probably shouldn't
read this one but I will Max Redick says
Tim Sam Cedar called you out on Twitter
for a debate the real question is will
he actually come on the show or just
pull the stunt you know I normally don't
like mentioning the guy because this is
why he does it
um I invited him on the show and then he
pulled some BS publicly where he claimed
some nonsense publicly I was like we'd
love to get people on the left on the
show he says you do it I say pick a date
he says how about this date I say we'll
pay for your flight we'll fly you out
get your hotel really excited to have
you Sam was one of the first he was
literally the First Media person ever
shout me out and compliment me uh during
Occupy Wall Street
and then privately he was like I'm not
going on your show and then I was like
okay and then he makes it this big thing
where it's like my fault or whatever I
think his whole shtick is just drama and
the reason I'm not interested in
following up with them is simply because
you know we like talking about
politicians presidents culture common uh
you know and comment on it and uh ideas
I think his whole thing is just ragging
on people like he would rag on Dave
Rubin all the time and I'm just like why
who cares dude Dave rubin's not doing
anything like Dave Rubin complains on
the internet the same as the rest of us
why should I care like I don't talk
about Sam ever because he's just another
guy who complains on the internet why
that's not affecting anybody you know
but for him to want to come on here at
this point I'm like dude I think you're
just gonna come on to do petty drama
stuff and I'm not really interested in
that you know I'd like to have a
conversation about ideas but I don't
think it would actually happen the other
issue too is and this one will be uh to
throw a little salt when I asked him
about deontology versus utilitarian
ethics he didn't understand it and then
when I tried using a pop culture
reference he turned like his his fans or
whatever use that as a meme so it's like
what's the point of trying to have a
conversation with someone who doesn't
understand Concepts and then laughs at
the idea when you try and explain it to
him just not there's nothing really
there
all right Vincent Young says your stream
is Shadow banned thank you for informing
us email shadowband timcast.com if you
believe you have evidence of us being
Shadow banned some people mentioned they
can't comment some people mention it's
not appearing on the on the channel page
like you they won't see it and we'd like
to collect that evidence for any
potential litigation people are seeing
me subscribed were also unsubscribed
that happened to me a lot of times oh
yeah yeah this is a crazy thing on
Twitter it's it's Relentless yeah and
it's like even with personalities and
personal friends that I know I'm like
hey I used to follow you what happened
and then it's like Ron Coleman was a big
one because I know for a fact I did not
unfollow him because he's a lawyer and
there's like a handful of lawyers I
follow on purpose because I want to see
their legal takes on things and then uh
one day I can't remember what happened
Ron tweeted I think about me not
following or something like that and
then I was like what no way I was like
all the like I follow all the lawyers I
even far I'm pretty sure I I follow or
maybe I don't follow anymore Mark Elias
the Democrat guy and then it was like
nope I was unfollowed from him and I'm
like okay I'm calling yes on that ain't
no way and uh Adrian Curry Adrienne
Curry she was on the show and I
mentioned I was like you don't follow me
on Twitter and she was just like what of
course I do and then she checked and she
was like what yeah bro she's in the chat
all the time you know uh watching the
show Twitter's playing dirty games
rain 20j says today I got an
advertisement warning me Lee zeldin will
try to repeal done restrictions and red
flag laws paid for by Kathy hokel for
governor I now lean even more towards
South than after that ad hey that's the
thing about ads they negative ads I
don't think work
because like you'll be like did you know
that Luke gradkowski wants to abolish
the ATF don't vote for him and I'm like
he does sounds good to me I like that
yeah I will vote I didn't know that I'm
telling you negative ads do work what
what doesn't work is sometimes the
targeting of those yeah right right yeah
they do work you got to be careful
all right let's grab some more redneck
Italian says everyone thinks the October
surprise will be political I think it
will be retribution in the beginning
middle October Mass arrests from FBI on
Maga Maybe
and then they'll be like look at these
Maga criminals see that would not
surprise me I mean like what we were
just discussing of the way that the FBI
is being incentivized to to find you
know there's there's there's great
demand for like white nationalists Maga
you know domestic terrorism they don't
have the supply that they need it would
not surprise me if if they say you know
two weeks before election day well we
found this like sleeper cells across the
country of Maga extremists who could
have possibly attacked election sites
that would not surprise me at all
all right Dragon sworn says the
borderline content label came out of the
ad apocalypse as a way to censor Stephen
Crowder when he hadn't violated their
terms of service sometimes called the
Crowder rule that's right
so this was a huge story there was a
dude from Vox who would refer to himself
in certain ways there's a video of him
saying here's what I am so Crowder did a
video commenting on it being like okay
Mr X Y and Z blah blah blah and then
they took that and said look at him he's
insulting him as these awful slurs and
YouTube was like he didn't break any
rules and the pressure campaign was so
intense they said okay you're right he
didn't break any rules but he was mean
so we're going to take away his partner
program
I remember when that happened and that
guy basically his old job was just
trying to get people who disagreed with
him demonetized yep I mean that's all
they do there's a very interesting uh
phenomenon on the internet now which is
basically like the old slip and fall
like ambulance Chasers yeah it's now
you've got this whole class of people on
the internet that try to manufacture an
opportunity to get somebody else
canceled it's wild
all right what is this what is this
well I'm gonna read this I don't
understand 117 BTN says your aversion to
unaccountability is understanding but
could you please tell me who works for
Wikipedia I I don't know Jimmy Wales
that's the Wikipedia guy I don't know
who works there or were you happy being
fed a curated series of information I'm
not sure what you're referring to Julian
Assange deserves GL incorrect Julian
Assange does not deserve jail
Julia Julian Assange deserves a medal
and a large cash prize and a nice
comfortable Mansion for which he can
retire in because he's done a lot of
really important things for this world
and they've destroyed his life because
of it
you don't got to agree with everything
when uh he got called out it was
actually pretty good
you guys are you guys familiar with
collateral murder
the Wikileaks release that was what 2010
Luke 2009 maybe
um I have to fact check that an Apache
helicopter killing journalists and he
called it collateral murder and he got
called I think by Colbert he said that's
editorialization like you're not just
publishing leaks and it's like well we
want to maximize reach look Wikileaks is
a news organization that specializes in
leaked information and whistleblowing
and stuff like that but I could agree I
was like yeah you know that was
editorializing calling it collateral
murder that is a that is a tag that's
not like a description of what happened
you know April 5th 2010 2010. but I
still think what Julian Assange was
doing was tremendously good for this
world and everyone wants to gut him
because of it Hillary Clinton for
obvious reasons yeah they don't like him
spilling the beans and Trump because he
knew Julian Assange knew what was going
on and he needed the evidence but
Assange was like I'm not you know I'm
not disclosing my sources which is what
a journalist should be doing and
Wikileaks has a way better record than
of course all the corporate media out
there they're doing what journalists
used to do especially when it came to
all the whistleblowing and all the
important things that journalism used to
expose you know right now we got the
window open can hear the trees rolling
the leaves are starting to fall it's
beautiful I love October oh it's great I
can't wait until we can start eating
pumpkins or you can smell like a
barbecue out there or maybe just leaves
burn leaves burning I love that smell
yeah it's a good time then winter comes
and it's like yeah I guess we'll go
snowboarding summer is is rough but a
good crisp summer night can be great as
well
the Roz Rodriguez says women love
DeSantis because when he speaks it's
like he's fearless and can protect a
damsel in distress his looks are just a
bonus ah see there you go I was speaking
on behalf of all women they all love him
all of them every single one
yeah no but I think uh DeSantis in
reality is just younger
and he doesn't have that baggage Trump
has
Trump came off as smarmy you know what I
mean like that that that uh grabbing by
The Who stuff as much as much people
might be like as locker room talk and
women really did not like that and you
need women to uh vote for you so
Rhonda Santos doesn't have that baggage
all right what do we got here
Stephen Ellis says the censorship on
YouTube is actually the five R's can't
forget Republican content that's right
and it's funny too because like we like
Republicans rag on Republicans you know
all the time it's if you look at the
polling
among Republicans their view of the
Republican party is extremely negative
it's I'm like good I mean yeah that's
that's what it is that's critical
thinking right like when you can
actually be critical of of your own side
is when you actually have a valid
Viewpoint yeah lots of Independent Media
get hit even if they're on the left but
if they question the narrative that's
that's the excuse that they need Nevada
loves guns says I have an echo B plus
thermostat in Nevada we had our
thermostats turned up to 78 degrees
every afternoon at 3 P.M we were able to
change it but by the time you realize it
happened the house was hot
yep
that's the future man you're gonna get
in your car and it's going to be
controlled it's not going to be charged
all that stuff's coming
everyone's going to get really excited
for their Teslas and then you're going
to sit down and it's going to be like
I'm sorry Dave I wasn't charging
you're gonna be like okay and then
you're going to try and leave and it's
going to be like quarantine Zone and I
made the joke a while ago so I'll make
it again but you get the point that's a
really good how voice by the way oh it
was really good I've not I've not
actually seen that movie I've only seen
parodies of it so I'm actually imitating
probably Family Guy or something I mean
it's gonna be horrific your Tesla's
gonna be like you didn't turn your
thermostat to 78 I'm driving you to the
compost pile
I'm liquidating you right now Michael
Hasting a mood engaged actually what I
think might happen is you're going to
have energy credits
and you're gonna have an app on your
phone and it's gonna be like where to
put your energy credits and you're going
to be like I need my car and then when
you slide the slider bar up on your car
to 100 everything else starts going down
it's going to be like TV and then carbon
credit and then the car auto drives to
the human compost and and automatically
The Lion King Circle of Life starts
playing yeah
I'd imagine you're in the car and you're
driving and it's gonna go it's gonna
show Fanfare and like horns playing on
the screen it's like you won You've Won
like what do I win it's like you can
join the circle of life
what does that mean the Tesla doors have
touch touch to open it's like a touch
button yeah and you're gonna go wow I
won let me out of the car
the model S has the Hermetic seal mode
yeah and then it just locks down and
blasts you and then you're it's gonna
close oh it's gonna yeah it's gonna
suffocate you yeah and then the car is
just gonna go straight up it's gonna
it's gonna drive it's gonna Zoom to 120
and then it's going to turn and the door
is going to open fling you out into the
compost
there was a movie there was a dystopian
movie I forgot the name of it maybe
someone in the chat room could remind me
but that everyone all the poor people
were trying to of course win an award
and the the award was they were all
murdered and they didn't know it and
they just thought they would move on to
the elite uh place the society
there's a movie called the island with
um Scarlett Johansson and I think uh
Ewan McGregor and it's like this colony
and every so often someone will win and
it's like they're like I did it I won
and in reality spoiler alert it is a
cloning facility for celebrities and
rich people and when you win you're
having your organs harvested but how do
you like it's look with sheep you know
we had Dan turnaround explain like the
Sheep don't know they're going to
slaughter and so they they'll go there
and they're happy and they love you if
you take care of them you walk them in
no one can see anything it's gone that's
what that's what it's like man you know
all right let's just uh let's just grab
one more uh really important one
Halo Mizu man says let's see if this
gets through it did if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and be the
notification you want to see in this
YouTube YouTube's not sending out
notifications people are having trouble
commenting and super chatting yeah I get
it we're coming close to a midterm
election and uh we don't really support
the uniparty establishment so we need
your help become a member at timcast.com
we're gonna have an after show coming up
it'll be up live about 11 pm on the
website and share the video be that
notification because if people choose to
share censorship becomes meaningless so
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me at timcast do you guys want to
shout anything out smug well thanks for
having me on you can catch us me and
Duncan ruthless podcast uh what's the
URL for that one what
ruthlesspodcast.com there you go or find
us on all the you know podcast platforms
obviously you can follow smug at
comfortably smug and follow me at
Michael Duncan on Twitter right on sweet
uh my website is youtube.com forward
slash we are change and someone a lot
smarter than me said this they said
quote they wouldn't need to censor us if
we were wrong and I think that's
definitely worth thinking about the The
Washington Post the CIA Amazon Jeff
Bezos paper wrote four years ago a very
interesting article that was entitled
the new sensors won't delete your words
they'll drown them out and I think
that's almost exactly what's happening
here I've been dealing with this issue
for way too long and you can check out
my struggles with YouTube for the many
years on youtube.com forward slash we
are change I'll give you all a quick
little explanation of how the media
works I get an email from The Washington
Post as I explained earlier they send me
a bunch of questions I respond to every
single one they said here are the tweets
where you claimed fraud and I went
through a handful and I said this tweet
isn't even about the election this tweet
is me saying Joe Biden won this me this
is a tweet of me saying the fraud
narrative is ludicrous like at what
point do you I was like did you read
these they clearly completely refute
your your assertion so what did she
write when asked about a series of
tweets pool sidestepped the question
incredible and then I was like excuse me
are you kidding I directly addressed
everything you said and the best part
was she then quoted me as saying
evidence of fraud is not proved fraud
authored the election
and I'm like so you agree that I like
you took my quote directly answering
your question included in your piece but
then claim I sidestepped it because this
is the game they'll play let's say
someone asks you a question they email
you smug and they say you know uh you
you said this about Trump what's your
answer if you give them the perfect
let's say they say something like you've
been accused of being an anti-vaxxer and
then your response is the vaccines are
safe and effective and we and I advise
everyone to follow the advice of their
doctors they will say okay well I can't
run that it makes him look good insane
so what they'll do is they'll say when
asked he gave us a blase answer and was
facetious yeah or sarcastic and so they
won't even show the quote and it's an
opinion anyway
that's how they do it well I'm also here
thank you guys very much for tuning in
really enjoyed having smug and Company
on the show excellent show for sure and
um yeah you guys can follow me on
Twitter minds.com at sour patchlitz as
well as sour patchlitz.me we will see
you all over at timcast.com become a
member because we're gonna have that
members only show Not So Family family
friendly at 11 p.m we'll see you all
then bye guys